peu
[Musique]
cool tu as vu ce qui se passe là tout le
monde au nom de quoi tu me parles tu
rigoles ou quoi la radio ou à la télé
les journaux tout le monde enfin à le
truc mais oui ce matin chez léo précis
m'attends à tout moment pas l'autre
c'est foutu c'est que j'ai eu trois
camps en ligne nantes à fond tu aurais
parlé aussi noter enfin qu il eut aussi
le passif il embarque ça veut dire que
tout le monde en parle à midi samedi
soir bien vu sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde en parle alors tu n'en parles
donc laissez kad et olivier mois ci
[Applaudissements]
vous avec ça se fait maintenant c'est
également ce cadeau
oui ça s'appelle un baladeur ça comment
es tu toi et toi voilà
[Musique]
gamin je suis trompé c'est bien quand
improvise comme ça qui arrive appuyé sur
tous les boutons en même temps si délire
bon alors qu'à l'est olivier bonsoir ce
à partir on va dire du bien
[Musique]
alors la fausse émission sur comédie
oui oui encore encore et encore et
encore à quelle heure 19h10 est-ce que
ça recommence l'année prochaine oui non
oui non oui non si on va regarder le
genre de truc que vous faites les autres
jean-michel pas de chute au théâtre de
la tortue qui pêche
ah ben je suis allé à bruxelles cet été
là bas les femmes sont toujours à
l'heure jean-michel pas de chute
une pléiade de sketches sa chute avec le
motard jeu motards je suis motard j'ai
mon uniforme à plat avec un pistolet
aussi pour arrêter les voleurs
vous savez moi les voleurs sont michel
pas de chute
un spectacle sans chute à mourir de rire
avec le maître nageur
alors la semaine dernière la semaine
dernière je suis allé chez la semaine
dernière je suis allé à la piscine à la
piscine dans mon quartier j'ai amené mon
maillot de bain jean michel latute au
théâtre de la tortue pêche avec en
première partie
alain prost
bravo à ces besoins
bon bah je comprends pourquoi je
comprends pourquoi ils vous garde sûr
que mélina les pro chavez en raison là à
mort c'est vraiment top alors pas fait
longtemps que c'est pas vu ça fait quand
même l'impression que ça fait des mois
mais alors pendant pendant votre absence
le public a travaillé de nouveaux petits
séismes
aie aie aie a gêné par exemple qu'on
soit dans un état d'esprit un peu un peu
baba un peu méditation oui
[Musique]
voilà allez y est vous glace ça va
dominique webb est alors moi j'ai
travaillé aussi un petit peu pour les
cadeaux imaginez vous gagnez souvent un
blindtest beaucoup oui ça vous arrive
souvent guidelines a eu d'ailleurs je
représente maintenant le comité d'une
france de blind test de france du
président du monde et apparemment il y
aurait des choses je suis à présent
quand vous gagnez le biarritz avait rien
de spécial à part ma considération
ben non il ya des vrais cadeaux à il ya
des danseuses
sa part à paris
il ya ma mère ouais vidéo sans pleurs il
est absolu d'avoir seulement décent
maintenant plus on aura des images dans
quinze jours on pourra faire apparaître
des éléphants roses ce sera ce sera
magique toujours le cas dans l'émission
durera pas daniel prévost matilda même
auriez menu les filets bruckner pascal
bruner et tata émissions mises à part
qu'à les oliviers je recevrai
[Musique]
le v10 aim talent
[Applaudissements]
emmanuelli
mathilda may
et pascal bruckner
ça tombe bien parce que tu sais que vous
avez cités sans palpation pas l'annoncer
comme ça tombe bien soit parti tout de
suite allée du pôle à ben alors j'ai pas
si vous êtes une émission pas la semaine
dernière parce qu'elle n'est pas tout le
monde en parle la semaine dernière mais
la semaine d'avant
ben on a eu ce qu'on va le voir là bas
que ça manque de filles un peu là non
ouais tiens vous venez vous asseoir à
côté de ça manque un peu de fil ça vous
embête pas
vous êtes prêts si vous avez regardé ça
pendant tout le jingle vous risquez pas
de bouger je vais vous dire j'ai regardé
laurent aznavour et voilà johnny johnny
l'extraordinaire chirac cabrel charme à
jeudi l'amour ça rend la peau plus douce
c'est moi quand je fais l'amour après
j'ai la peau plus douce assez marrant ça
c'est plus moite aussi et surtout grâce
à l'adn on sait maintenant que lou 17
n'est pas la fille d'yves montand
patrick bruel
si tu me quitterait je souffrais pierre
bellemare c'est ce qui est rare qu'un
soir il va venir
oui je sais mais on va le vendre alors
comment vendriez vous un vibromasseur
qui se recharge sur l'allume-cigare
sherzad oui l'objet que je vais vous
tendre doit absolument être utilisée sur
un parking et en aucun cas pendant la
marche des véhicules à partir du moment
où vous avez branché sur m6 gars le
vibromasseur que je vais battre vous
proposer tout est possible le nirvana
peut arriver et donc il est impossible
de jouir de nirvana cyr en même temps
est en train de doubler nos deux chaînes
de 2,2 sur le taux est ce que vous
préférez hitler ou staline et en connaît
qui se dit [ __ ] c'est pas tomber sur
vous suivez tous qui dit la patte ubuntu
parce que là vous nous faites un peu un
politique
vous savez ce qui se passe quand on fait
une politique non mais je vais voir
d'abord vous êtes mosaïque et serge et
puis à ça surtout
[Musique]
c'est la punition c'est i muvrini même
pétards par jour en ce moment mais là on
peut pas répondre par oui ou par non il
faut donner un chiffre
reconnue s'est dit plus il y aurait dix
mois de moins 3 je partais patron que
j'ai toujours c'est ce soir faut qu'il
soit brillant
ouais faut qu'il soit brillant ailier
toujours ça il m'énervait parce que ça
vous ça veut dire qu'il n'avait pas
confiance en moi rien géorgie où ça et
je m'appelle dany brillant mais voilà
c'est resté comme ça
voilà vous avez été brillants ils jouent
toujours des rôles de jeunes anconina en
fait un des plus vieux que les rôles
qu'il a incarné s'était jusque là je
pourrai le dire elle avait bien sûr je
suis dans 53 47 40 mais ça va non oui
avoue trouver ça un peu géronto et
préférer dany brillant qu'elle agit à
bout c'est une question d'âge mais
brillant vous avez quel âge a votre avis
vous allez me répondre en chantant c'est
sympa à faire bondir me cacher j'ai
quand même du mal à ce dernier coup de
foudre
j'ai rencontré une autre fille mais
celle là elle avait un chemisier rose
elle voulait savoir quelle était mon âge
elle s'est trompée mais peu importe car
je crois qu'ils se passe quelque chose
entre nous ouais
les coups droits
c'est tout à l'heure c'était tout le
monde en a parlé
non le best-of de la dernière émission
de tout le monde en fait j'ai vu ce que
vous avez raté belle émission belle
émission
la rencontre entre pierre bellemare et
laurent gerra restera comme un grand
moment de télévision
vous savez qui je vais accueillir
maintenant non bon je suis bien de dire
non vous êtes sympas breton cette
voiture alors jacques à lui maintenant
un humoriste away un comédien en rien un
nul et un écrivain un animateur
ah oui en un seul homme c'est daniel
prévost
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
b
soir
alors une trêve au jeu mais désolé de
vous avoir à le mettre à l'eau ces deux
grands partis bête
ce master semestre alors d'après vous
est ce que vous préférez un triomphe
romain ou une minute de silence pour
saluer votre arrivée dans cette émission
est la minute de silence c'est d'ici 20
ans la minute de silence et d'ici 20 ans
ouais vous préférez que j'arrête mois
dans vingt ans de silence en 20 ans dans
20 ans mais pas tout de suite
bon donc là vous faire le tri au fromage
avec paisible pour gagner
[Musique]
à
vic mackey
kad et o je vous avertis daniel prévost
a déclaré la demi sphère consensuelle de
l'époque ne permet pas tout c'est vrai
donc pas de va ne déplacez pas de
conneries sur le sexe non noms du rap
abidjanais voilà c'est un daniel prénom
on va il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de
choses à vendre ce soir oui moi je ne
vends rien je donne tout blanc c'est moi
qui vont s'attirer qui s'appelle un
couple de notre temps c'est un roman
satirique au cherche midi éditeur 1 et
alors je vais le vendre à votre place
donc c'est le portrait d'un seul
portrait d'un bouffon peut dire non oui
on peut dire ça c'est un petit peu
excessif mais enfin bon c'est le
portrait d'un homme tout à fait moyen
quoi et puis bon et c'est une vie de
couple
c'est un type dont qui s'appelle denis
qui a épousé une fille qui s'appelle
mirail voilà et déjà le jour du mariage
il avoue devant toute la famille réunie
qu'il attend qu'il a fricoté avec la
cousine celle-ci présence de tout ça une
des premières scènes du lit est une des
premières scènes du livre en plus ça a
pris là un enfant est un garçon qui se
base sur une fille qui s'appelle du set
et là il avouait sa femme qui l'a trompé
oui mais il a du mal à le lui avouer
ouais et ironie le dire chérie je suis à
dire que je considère prêt que tu dis
parce qu'elle et ses espaces à 2 heures
du matin il revient d'un comité
d'entreprise et il dit et tu étais sûr
de quoi tu dis je crois que tu es trop
près il est trop près du grand rien
comme ça se passe quand sa femme il
appelle crache tout net je souligne
voilà c'est sympa je souligne un swing
ils partent à venise pendant quatre
jours ils sont détournés sur tahiti et à
la fin il ya le mariage du fils et
savadra mariage l'histoire c'est assez
drôle c'est tirer de ce qu est ce que
vous aviez oui c'est ça c'est quelques
sketchs que j'avais fait et puis une
deuxième partie de spectacle que j'avais
fait donc là cette histoire de couple et
je me suis dit je vais en faire un jeu
en faire un roman je vais mettre les
événements comme ça de sketches à
l'intérieur ça tire et des services
exactement mais aussi donc on revient de
voir prévost prévost écrivain maintenant
on va voir
[Musique]
prévost comédien alors c'est un film de
christian gion qui s'appelle les
insaisissables alors c'est l'histoire
d'un agent immobilier qui est menacée de
saisie par un huissier infernale
évidemment qu'ils aient joué par daniel
prévost il ya du terrible sur les mecs
sont obligés d'apprendre un peu la loi
pour savoir comment devenir
insaisissable ans à s'élancer dans leur
code de procédure pénale est un des
jeunes gens qui a trouvé la parade
contraire contrôler les huissiers voilà
la faille
là ça se passe comme ça tout ça se passe
autour de lui gravitent il invente
pardon tout les toutes les russes tous
les stratagèmes pour échapper à cette
nuit sied revêche manigancé je m'appelle
rebelles ont dit que ma morsure est
mortelle ma maîtresse me laisse en
liberté quand elle n'est pas là c'est
légal ça je les lis chez elle
[Musique]
m grumberg huissier de justice en tout
cas pas du chien les cantalous suppose
que vous êtes commissaire de police 24
des commissaires s'il vous plaît pas il
n'y a pas d'hésitation d'identité il a
juste eu violation domicile je suis
lucide justice article 21 du 9 juillet
1991 vous n'êtes autorisés à entrer dans
certains cas dans un domicile privé tous
à cette juridiction d'accord la pratique
s'est par contre je la pratique je
m'assois dessus et ce que vous appelez
vous juridisme c'est la stricte
application de la loi
oh ça ira pour cette fois si je
comprends bien si tous les français
connaissaient le ncpc vous n'auriez plus
de boulot couche on pourra fermer la
moitié des études ccisam insaisissable
ça dépend comment c'est trop méfiez-vous
janam ya pire qu'un huissier à
l'huissier humilié l'an dernier alors
que tous les moyens pour échapper aux
huissiers bien il ya du cheval dans le
personnage et du cheval bah ça sent un
peu tous et tous ces gens de
l'administration
cette salle marcel bien ça oui j'essaye
de faire ce que je peux alors pour le
dîner de cons justement vous incarniez
cheval vous avez eu le césar 99 du
meilleur second rôle pour le premier
rôle c'est prévu pour quand césar du
meilleur bas ça va être tout de suite
derrière l'émission mamba d'avis que ça
se passe chez nous c'est sympa ouais
alors au cinéma vous avez fait toutes
sortes de films si vous avez fait aussi
bien
mon curé chez les thaïlandaises que j'ai
jamais vue en plus j'ai jamais vu mais
j'étais très content à manses curé chez
les thaïlandais ne les ai pas vus et
vous avez aussi des trucs chefs-d'oeuvre
comme uranus quoi de de claude berri ça
vous en intensité vous oui complètement
moi je fais mon métier de comédien
geslin plombières il va là partout ça
peut aller chez un mec d'extrême gauche
d'extrême droite et on ne va pas lui
demander sa carte mais c'est vrai ou si
elle savait vous dire ça simple pour moi
ma conduite est très simple c'est que je
dis bah moi je fais ce métier là ça est
aussi bien que d'agresser les vieilles
ou piquer des sacs à main c'est clair à
la sse de tous pour plus est très
simpliste
non mais c'est incroyable parce que vous
avez là vous commencez dans la vérité si
je mens 2 oui tout à fait vous faites
quoi là je fais le directeur d'une
grande
succursale de distribution d'achat oui
oui la vérité si je mens contre la
grande distrib c'est pour ça c'est la
gare ça s'appelle la grande distribution
et vous faites quoi dans le patron du
moins j'espère oui c'est ça ce que je
viens de vous lire on n'écoutait pas
donc je fais je fais ce directeur d'une
grande centrale d'achat distribution et
qui essayent d'arnaqués et puis il va se
faire arnaquer peut-être à la fin voilà
et bien alors il ya un troisième prévost
évidemment c'est le prévôt humoriste
jean peu plus loin sous les tirs
d'artillerie un état parfait américaine
lotois qui n'a pas fait l'émission il
manque un départ de à qu'est ce que
c'est il faut pratiquer chez vous mon
cher ami
c'est pourquoi ce qu'on fait tous mais
je fais ce matin je fais pas le même
geste c'est pour ça après j'ai pas dit
de bienvenue j'ai pas négociable j'ai
pas pensé franchement que ans ready une
grossièreté et comme tu l'aies merci
beaucoup d'honneur donc on continue avec
prévost humoristes
[Musique]
avec la cassette d'un spectacle qui
s'appelle décollage immédiat avec le
fameux garage grand spectacle dense que
tout le spectacle ou spectacles et bien
c'est un spectacle vous avez donné en 91
incessants et pardonner un j'ai vendu et
cher a été salué par la critique à
l'époque j'ai vu des gens que j'ai
remarqué d'ailleurs votre fort
intelligemment au dos un certain nombre
de critiques de l'époque évidemment et
les gens les gens avaient trouvé sa déjà
très bien pourtant c'est en 91 n'est pas
c'était avant la guerre du golfe bah oui
ça va sauter et du décollage immédiat
est la guerre des gaules est d'ailleurs
guillaume juste après la guerre du golfe
elle a servi à rien parce que c'est la
mienne est toujours là elle a quand même
fait deux cent cinquante mille mains
voilà alors ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire quoi on vous et qu'un aller-retour
bagdad koweit city bagdad ça fait 250
morts
c'est ça que ça veut dire maintenant
tranquillement on a tous rentrer chez
nous parce que c'était important de le
dire on a plombé l'ambiance
il faut plonger dans l'émission ça fait
une école de plomb de plombage est plein
de jeux d'ailleurs c'est ce que je me
plonge moi même mes dents je me plonge
mesdames je me fais mon ciment tu vois
je prends à une petite ruelle
mais quand on commet des ministres l
comment tu fais pour voir à l'intérieur
quand tu prépares a besoin var je sais
où elle trouve avec la langue
[Rires]
et ça y est et bien alors au delà de
l'écrivain du comédien de l'humoriste en
va un petit peu parlé parlé de vous vous
avez publié plusieurs livres moi que je
ne connaissais pas que j'ai découvert il
ya pas très longtemps
il ya coco benatia le pont de la révolte
qui éclaire différemment votre votre
personnage au personnage médiatique
n'est pas en ligne avec votre wii c'est
à dire que on se traîne sur des années
comme ça d histoire même si je crois que
tout le monde est pareil on a tous des
cons mon idée
et des cadavres dans le placard je crois
que ces cinq ans à l'époque du petit
rapporteur je peux vous donner cette
histoire à l'époque du pire à porter ça
c'est de la grande époque du tac à mes
fans et moi
le gala de fin de soirée ce matin tous
havrais jacques martin tout ça vous
découvrez que vous êtes en fait
d'origine algérienne doit la vie à ça
c'est bien ce que vous ne saviez pas
plus précisément d'ailleurs kabyle vous
avez appris comment bah c'est marqué
dans le livre c'est parti j'ai marqué
son magnifique j'allais voir une vieille
tante à l'hôpital
je n'ai pas vu depuis je crois depuis 20
ans sur un visage marqué dans le livre
ses marques et d'enlever cette vieille
tante que qu'il n'avait pas vue depuis
une vingtaine d'années lui dit un jour
tu sais que ton père est algérien et tu
t'appelles aït salem et donc vous
déplacer dans l'eau c'est vraiment parce
que c'est pas vrai tout ça le vrai nom
est à ce moment là vous comprenez
pourquoi vous avez des cheveux frisés
parler oui tout à fait un oui mais moi
je vais vous dire encore autre chose que
je vous avais dit chez vous l'a
d'ailleurs il ya je crois un an je crois
que j'étais venu vous dire
mais comme là il ya plus d'audience
c'est plus important donc c'est que je
crois avoir le sentiment et va vraiment
pensé qu au moment où j'ai passé le
concours pour entrer au conservatoire tu
vois c'est à dire il ya 40 ans et j'ai
été recalée j'étais co kg d irrésistible
j'étais drolatique et tout tu vois
j'avais les cheveux noirs et frisés et
j'ai persisté à dire à attirer votre
jour que je suis j'étais certain que on
n'avait pas accepté au conservatoire
parce que j'avais la tête d'un malade
mais à ce moment là daniel prévost non
seulement comprend pourquoi les cheveux
frisés me comprend aussi pourquoi vous
étiez contre la guerre d'algérie en fait
d'une façon à roue et problème le
problème c'est simple pas si je te dis
que ça non plus ça me problème un bond à
6 et pas à d'autres problèmes sérieux
problèmes tandis que vous ferez oui
c'est ça non voilà
[Musique]
donc on parle pas de la guerre d'algérie
mais on évoque d'une certaine en les
vols d'une certaine baisse alors donné
un prénom mais là si tu veux alors
excuse moi ah bon mais jusqu'à quand
vous allez provoquer des choses cette
nature attendez ça vous va bien après
vous vous est il a présenté un jeu là
télégramme à g avec des poissons aux
pendus de chaque côté dans les sacs en
plastique
après auxerre n'a pas eu ça oui c'est
vrai d'année ce qui les attend c'est
vrai jean daniel
c'est sur un daniel regarde ce qu'on va
faire c'est que vous avez eu beaucoup de
vous avez beaucoup de deux mètres dans
le métier il ya eu michel serrault il ya
eu beau varier les genres jan mais il y
en a dont vous êtes beaucoup plus proche
que tous les autres si vous l'appelez
derrière votre compagnon de jeu et on va
nous voir et patrick fiori magnéto serge
bragdon loisirs on attendait
[Musique]
l'accusation se fait pas tellement dans
la boutique ils te prends moi pourquoi
on peut on peut bien vous dire ce qu'on
achète une petite portion de chercher de
voeux allez arrêtez arrêtez arrêtez
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
donnez lui la saisir les branches dans
le petit rapporteur le boudin blanc le
fameux boudin blanc ça fait plaisir de
mars à pékin et des proches
j'ai beaucoup aimé travailler avec lui
mais c'est la vérité c'est votre préféré
votre compagnon de jeu que je vous ai
pas dit que c'était mon préféré ça fait
deux favoris de ces bons préféré ça ne
va pas faire et je vous ai pas dit ça
bien avant les années déclare ou pas oui
vous avez déclaré
mais s'il faut oui c'est que je ne suis
pas chanceux nié je préfère avoir l'air
que de balancer mon petit couplet c'est
à dire rien c'est bien
alors vous allez avoir l'air on va faire
un truc alors je signale à nos amis
présents ici on peut bouger pendant le
jingle maintenant ah bon
[Musique]
m
en bouche on fait quoi
[Musique]
mais vous est certainement l'habitude
n'a pas bougé pendant le jingle que
maintenant ils arrivent plus à bouger
pas en mesure ce soir exceptionnellement
ont peu bougé pendant le jingle et super
conditionné thierry tu sais voilà alors
donc c'est une interview sans la bouche
donc je vous posais des questions et
vous allez me répondre sans parler c'est
une interview sans la bouche de quelle
humeur et vous le matin quand vous vous
réveillez
oui d'accord
d'accord moi j'aimerais pas trois buts
avec lui quelle est la première chose
que vous faites on vous levant quelle
est votre position préférée pour prendre
votre petit déjeuner j'ai dix ans
imaginons c'est un peu comme dans votre
livre là un couple de 1 coupe de notre
temps là votre fille vous annonce
qu'elle est enceinte vous réagissez
comme en ya pire et si c'est votre fils
qui vous annonce qu'il est en simple
réagissait comment imaginer c'est comme
dans le film les insaisissables de
questions géants initiés débarque chez
vous faites quoi vous sortez dans la rue
le matin il ya un clochard qui vous
demandent l'aumône voulu donner une
petite pièce et il vous dit que c'est
pas assez vous réagissez comme en tout
si vous arrivez sur le tournage de la
vérité de tout le monde c'est tout le
monde se marre tout sens en vous voyant
et vous savez pas pourquoi
d'accord pensez à quoi
non je ne vais pas alors au déjeuner à
une figurante qui vous drague vous êtes
du genre à couper court tout de suite
ouais mais ça de façon on avait dit
qu'on n'en parlait pas mais maintenant
je suis un peu voilà donc après une
journée de tournage
vous rentrez chez vous et le clochard
vous insulte à nouveau puis il est passé
le matin votre femme vous annonce
qu'elle est enceinte de l'huissier et
vous vous péter les plombs c'est comment
quand vous péter les plombs et de
montrer que tu as l'air
[Rires]
alors vous allez gagner un cadeau
oui
on rallume merci donc j'ai lu votre
petit canot merci qui rien à redire
certains balla diouf le papa dégonfle
pas c'est bon c'est bon j'ai senti
l'énergie atomique a ouai bah écoute
pendant toute l'émission je me trompe et
le pousse pas perdre mon temps tu vois
c'est vrai j'ai un panneau c'est pour ça
que j'ai demandé de l'eau propre tir et
fait un gros plan sur mon pouce pas fait
un gros plan sur le pouce du penher
gropper là c'est bien bas reste comme ça
jusqu'à la fin dans une caméra diverger
serge sur la la c'est bon la migration
oim
alors déjà 8 millions d'entrées pour
taxi 2 le film où il incarne emilien un
jeune flic un peu gaffeur il est
également à la fiche de 6 tac d'alain
berbérian avec richard anconina tout le
monde en parle voici et frédéric
diefenthal
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir on va faire un bel adieu regarde
ça balladur c4 qui a invité sa fredo
frédéric diefenthal donc effectivement
la fiche de taxi 2 avec samy naceri
marion cotillard et mathieu aubert gains
à la fiche de 6 pas qu'on va en parler
d'alain berbérian avec richard anconina
vous tournez en ce moment belphégor avec
sophie marceau
alors les six pack films nous en a parlé
déjà avec richard anconina
on va en parler avec le 2ème flics du
film c'est frédéric diefenthal
[Musique]
je ne sais pas le faire
oui ça recommence alors donc après le
juge est une femme
après taxi après six pack n'ai pas peur
d'être cantonné dans les rôles de flic
ah ça c'est la question qu'on pose alors
comment c est cool c'est la bonne
question si tu veux mais créé pour lui
c'est déjà ce qui va répondre de toute
façon tu sais pas la corrosion
non mais je crois que je vais enterrés
là c'est vrai qu'ils avaient d'ailleurs
je viens de finir le dernier épisode du
juge est une femme et et dans belphégor
je ne suis pas flic dans les prochains
en projet loin de là encore alors on va
écouter un petit peu de la musique
qu'ils ont écoutée un petit peu de la
musique de six pack c'est bien peur ça
[Musique]
on peut rallumer pas je suis pas ah
ouais ça fait peur mais le film fait
peur d'ailleurs cessé un thriller plus
qu'un polar dont c'est un vrai thriller
qui fait qui fait peur il ya c'est une
piste ça va tout droit c'est une traque
c'est pas plus compliqué que sa yamaha
rentre pas dans les méandres
psychologiques des personnages quoi ils
veulent abattre un mec et ils vont aller
jusqu'à se mettre hors la loi pour ça
alors vous vous appelez souvent j'enfile
bien rentrés dans un arbre psychologique
plus grandes maintenant tout de suite là
ouais c'est moi bien dit mois après la
boulette a fait des dalles monsieur
prévost je suis marié monsieur je vais
crever renaître le doigt le pousse dans
le vert quand je voudrais pas non pas
parce que je me dis dieu lui-même prêt
ou un autre c'est chez ni dieu ni
sentiments à doit pas s'ennuyer
elle doit pas s'ennuyer palm pre web web
au sein du palais trésorier vous plomber
une émission chirurgie à je te raconte
pas à temps j'ai commencé à me chauffer
1 tu vas regretter
donc je ne sais pas moi je suis derrière
je sais pas comment vous faites sûrement
contraire comment je fais le modeste
fait un plan sur moi je vous dit j'adore
la la la la
ils veulent passer j'adore mais il a le
plan il a bien failli ou le plan b je
veux rien je le plan là là c'est là là
mais à oui d'accord l'appui de rouge
maintenance n'existe plus de ça non
d'accord enfin oui et moi moi je sais tu
es je suis de la télévision
préhistorique vous souvenez de ça
[Musique]
il s'appelait patrick sabatier qu'elle
avait un autre qui s'appelait jean
pierre foucault
à ce point m
[Musique]
jean pierre foucault mesdames messieurs
bien alors on continue frédéric
diefenthal donc vous jouez le rôle de
sol comme j'essayais d'expliquer
oui vous êtes un flic un peu nouvelle
mode avec les derniers logiciels etc
quand vous découvrez qu'il ya un
serial-killer que le que le meurtrier
c'est le même qui tue tout le monde là
ce moment là vous devenez vous engager
auprès de colina c'est vrai qui lui
fonctionne sol fonctionne plus le
personnage que je joue avec ses avec ses
émotions et son instinct que par paris
ce que quelqu'un avec sa tête et en plus
de ce sur quoi ils croient que l
ordinateur on peut tout faire que
l'autre est très docile et les aident
dans le film finalement aide mais bon
faut lui donner à manger mal et lozère
votre histoire dépasse toute logique
meurtrière pour une raison simple
évidente
j'ai pas de mobile
éventration du sujet à l'aide d'un
instrument tranchant à l'asnl a rejailli
disait
au ménisque il s'agit d'un psychopathe
le tiers de tous imaginant triaire qui
échappe à toute logique policière
humaine
j'ai peut-être un peu pour les français
je déconne pas là ton truc c'est du
délire on a plus aucun soutien plus
aucune légitimité rien et toi tu voudras
impliqué là dedans une nana en plus
avant de vous donner ma réponse je
connais beaucoup pour nos moindres
détails on me dit où je réfléchis et
après je dirais si choqué
[Musique]
jusqu'à maintenant vote leur a
complètement foiré
[Musique]
ce pack d'alain berbérian avec frédéric
bernard richard anthony maraka
mastroianni alors diefenthal
on va parler un petit peu de vous
maintenant on l'a dans quinze jours vous
apprenez par votre part une vieille
tante annoncé pas vous ça c'est des
filles
vous étiez un élève moyen vous avez
quitté l'école à ces taux moyen moyen
moi quand même temps vous quittez
l'école assez tôt vous faites de la
coiffure
j'ai été j'ai fait une école hôtelière
avant il est devenu comédien
complètement par hasard un jour est un
pote que vous aviez perdu de vue vous le
rencontrez il est dans un cours de
théâtre vous l'accompagnez et trois
semaines plus tard
trois semaines plus tard ouais je
précise toujours trois semaines plus
tard mais c'est vrai c'est important
trois semaines plus tard dans un pays en
pleine nuit et lancel et il rêve qu'il
est dans une comédie musicale
je le dis pas je le dire je les ai
presque jamais dit ça donc vous
réveiller en pleine nuit c'est le flash
et je vais même vous préciser quelque
chose oui de plus drôle encore c'est que
dans ce rêve j'étais sur une voiture
qu'on me croie ou page était sur une
voiture ses victimes révèlent ces taxis
en croire ses missions
allez rêver non non non j'ai dit mieux
oui j'étais pas tout seul sur la voiture
n'avait pas de visage aïe aïe aïe mes
amis non là on est vraiment fort qui
fait ce rêve et le lendemain matin au
réveil du bhv tracteur puisque j'ai eu
cette espèce de jeu vous aurez des
nations unies tiens je vais essayer un
nouveau métier que j'en avais signé pas
mal ouais je me tiens je vais essayer
celui-là voilà c'est un axe et laure
d'ailleurs maintenant parfois frédéric
diefenthal certaines nuits se réveille
aussi en ayant peur parce qu'il dit
peut-être qu'un jour ça va s'arrêter
c'est un syndrome cendrillon de cela
c'est à dire qu'à un moment on a peur
que l'on sache pu faire son métier
c'est vrai il pas toutes les nuits n'ont
pas toutes les mêmes choses encore non
mais c'est vrai qu'on soit gardée c'est
bon on peut se faire des flips pendant
se dire moi je crois que c'est en fait à
chaque fois qu'on on pense qu'avec au
départ quand on prend les cours des
coûts de transit de l'expérience je veux
en fait plein de chaleur fait plein de
films ça va être génial le savoir tout
faire tout sera facile
et finalement c'est le contraire vous
sentez que vous en plus neuf
à chaque film et puis il ya bien on
apprend tout le temps passe et ce qui
est formidable c'est que vraiment vous
avez serait vous décidez d'être acteur
vous avez une espèce de boulimie de
d'apprendre vous allez voir des films
tous les jours vous achetez des
cassettes vidéo vous regardez des
kilomètres de cassettes vidéo c'est
quand j'ai découvert que c'était un
métier qu'on apprenait qu'il fallait
travailler au niveau des bus moi je me
suis dit je vais apprendre un nouveau
métier mais je comprenais pas con
qu'on travaille pour ça je croyais qu'on
arrivait qu'on monte sur une scène et
condé de guignol et et que ça s'arrêtait
là j'écris ça y est les personnes a pris
un coup j'ai pris des cours la semaine
c'est court viriot 1 est alors dans le
juge est une femme avec florence pernel
là aussi c'est un coup de bol qui ont
début vous y allez pour pour un épisode
et vous êtes devenu récurrent ouais ça
qu'est la télé devenir récurrent s'est
lancé florence mais à lyon ont fini
celle ces derniers jours de tournage à
dernière scène et qui dans la voiture me
disent ça te dirait de revenir je
m'arrête je dirais de revenir jeudi bas
tout intimidé way et puis elle a tenu
parole
qu'est-ce qui se passe et là autour du
civc muller regarder la seconde
non mais arrêtez moi je viens de loin je
viens de garches pas quand même désordre
d'agde à venir là tu feras pas ton
boulot attaque est pas le temps que je
suis là c'est moi je tiens
vandal comme vous êtes en train de
devenir une star
il faut s'habituer on va vous poser des
questions on va poser des questions cons
parce que on va poser tout temps des
questions un peu imbécile comme ça donc
on bouge comme jingle albert jambon
ce soir bien alors comment vous êtes
prêts à les leur poser une première
question qui est la question dit
clotilde courau c'est une question qui
est inventé par clotilde courau est ce
que par amour vous embrasse seriez sans
fois de suite des chaussettes sales
non non et vous daniel o moi je respecte
pas les questions aussi compris d'accord
ça s'appelle l'interview nul mais on
peut dire nulles et qu'on a bien sûr
alors maintenant la question la question
pierre bellemare il est magnifique parce
qu'il a des stomates la question en
moins la question
pierre bellemare comment voudriez vous
un vibromasseur qui se branche sur
l'allume-cigare frédéric diefenthal
moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] fume pas
[Applaudissements]
de monsieur près vous je suis marié je
sais ça fait trois fois bien elles sont
hélas ans est-ce que vous préféreriez
vous réincarner écoutez bien en lara
fabian en céline dion ou ans hélène
ségara qui pas lara fabian non je sens
que tu as envie de dire ça je n'ai pas
bien aller et laura salignon avis bien
ces lignes on à céline dion tabac je
sais bien céline dion quel est votre
émission préférée vous préférez être
privé de sexe ou privés de câlins privé
515e aucune de ces pays mais vous êtes
objets ou leur a fait mal a pris 8 6
privé de lara fabian
privé de sexe se priver de callac si
vous préférez sexe privé de sexe a opté
au cas là parce qu'avec les câlins je me
dis que ça rédac a évidemment bon ça
peut le faire c'est vrai donc finalement
j'ai les 2 quel est le mot le plus quand
on amour pour vous merci encore oui oui
où le race à viande
oui fabien non oui oui vous pensez
frédéric diefenthal que pour réussir à
la télé il faut être une ordure un
pourri ou un [ __ ] points
je crois qu'avec un peu des trois ça
peut marcher vous avez fait de la télé
il a répondu c'est pas réussi mois
pourra terminer sur une question de
culture politique esprit nous citer les
quatre prétendants de l'opposition pour
la mairie de paris
athos porthos et aramis et l'autre c'est
comment des gens là c'est dur c'est dur
ça a quel sens les quatre prétendants
balladur oui très bien je suis soufflé
pas souffle pas m'at on ne souffle pas
dur
que des gagnants faut croire que oui
sylvain n'diaye rocchi vertement le toit
il a dit quelque chose mais n'écoute pas
nier le prévaut au sahara et vous les
connaissez pas non je sais ça n'a aucune
importance je sais simplement pour
montrer que finalement tout le monde
s'en fout il ce truc là à dire que la
presse en parle toute la journée sa télé
l'ensemble de la journée leur avion
pendant toute la journée et tout le
monde s'en fout la preuve du grand
chelem pas su c'est important de le
savoir faire et c'est moi aussi vous
allez répondre olivier salé trop dit ou
pas assez gains séguin séguin oui tiberi
tiberi oui balladur
mais pour l'opposition le dialogue en a
quatre mais la position
séguin à la fio
je n'aime pas encore plus étonné que
quand il conduit son taxi dans le film
c'est du savoir des couples et sa
télévision de l'an 2000 c'est le
troisième millénaire
et oui c'est ça
[Musique]
ce matin ça
journée
[Musique]
j'ai démarré avec lui
la fni colossal
françoise hardy
[Applaudissements]
soir heureusement c'est la vrai que je
suis sûr que vous connaissez les travaux
je vous embrasse
pour mon fils et mon mari qui vous adore
et moi je suis toujours oui tifa gentils
ces cas les oliviers et avec quel talent
prof
françois je suis sûr vous n'êtes pas du
tout contente des chansons que j'ai
choisi a quand même y en avait 2 3 qui
sait que la première en tous les cas
vous n'avez pas du tout mais les autres
ça va je n'en suis un petit peu fatigué
et c'est normal oui comment ça va ça va
vous avez l'air surpris devant voit un
moi aussi je très heureux de vous voir
sérieusement alors vous aimez vous êtes
très critique sur vos premiers ne
voulait réécouter jamais ils parient sur
les derniers aussi en tous les cas il ya
une chanson de vous qui sort
actuellement et qu'on écoutera encore
dans dix ans dans les émissions de
télévision
magnéto ch
il l'a remercié en le raccompagnant vous
parler sérieusement les journaux fait
six heures
je manque d'originalité c'est vrai
savez-vous de ses parents pour la
première fois vraiment faim c'est pour
toi et puis par que quinze jours à tout
petit peu
dois je comprends que vous avez passé
ces cases horrible le jour sans compter
les heures
puisque vous partez en voyage
puisque nous quittons ce soir
mon coeur fait son apprentissage
jean
je veux sourire avec ou
un jeu
[Musique]
marche avant
du coup droit
et vous
je vais préparer
joie
[Musique]
instant on le train démarre
je resterai sur le quai
[Musique]
et vous
autre bouquet
promettez moi d'être bien ça
pensez à main
tous les jours
j'ai retourné
[Musique]
jacques dutronc puisque vous partez en
voyage
voilà l'album duquel ce single est
extrait je trouve incroyable on la pas
et ça pour moi c'est la définition de la
classe voilà tous les dosettes place à
la chanson c'est d'abord la chanson qui
est magnifique et s'avèrent plus
toujours urgence en 1935 la chanson
c'est une chanson 230 à cette chanson de
jeunes de jean nohain y est chanté par
jean sablon
alors qu'est ce qui a changé entre la
version de l'époque et la version
d'aujourd'hui parce que là dedans le
clip qu'on vient de voir c'est vous qui
commencez alors que dans l'extrait que
j'aime passer c'est jean sablon qui
commanda parce que mireille était
quelqu'un c'était une espèce de lutins
très très fantasque plein d'humour etc
je trouvais que ça correspondait mieux à
jacques aussi d'être la personne qui
s'en va et moi amoureuse transie qui
restent sur le quai mais il n'a pas été
satisfait à 100% puisqu'il a tenu à ce
qu'on refasse cette chanson pour son
propre album qui n'est pas encore prêt
et où c'est lui qui reste sur le quai et
moi leur parle un peu du cd là
cada sais pas monsieur cas du suma bravo
habitées je suis attention
vous avez sur ces gars là alors si une
entreprise familiale il ya le duo avec
jacques dutronc qui votre mari il ya
votre fils qui joue de la guitare
les photos de l'album ont été faites par
votre premier amour jean marie périer on
s'est vraiment amusé
oui mais enfin bon c'est pas comme ça
pour toutes les chansons quand même il
ya beaucoup de reprises qui sont très
bien d'ailleurs on va en parler mais
pourquoi vous trouvez qu'il ya un manque
de talent dans l'écriture des chansons
ce moment vous mais c'est vrai que au
moment où je devais m'attaquer à la
conception à la préparation de cet album
j'avais certaines chansons inédites et
donc il m'en fallait d'autres et les
mélodies que j'ai reçus ne m'inspirait
pas vraiment et et donc je me suis dis
plutôt que plutôt que de s'acharner sur
des mélodies qui n'en valent peut-être
pas la peine
il vaut mieux aller vers le patrimoine
et je ne savais pas que au même moment
des tas d'autres chanteurs chanteuses
non seulement en france mais aussi en
angleterre j'ai tant dormi ou par tous
avaient la même idée alors là vous êtes
très en forme vous êtes très vert très
très gai tout ça l'album est pas
terrible et ça me fait très plaisir
l'album est pas terriblement guerre mais
jamais jamais jamais a dit les belles
mélodies ne sont pas guéris or justement
vous avez essayé moi une belle mélodie
c'est vrai que j'y puise ou bien alors
justement françoise hardy a repris une
phrase célèbre pour parler de son album
vous dit pas les chants désespérés sont
les plus beaux sait de qui je veux dire
je connais là je connais parfaitement
cette cette citation ou fait mais je
vais vous citer la formule de prêt vert
s'est lassé les chants désespérés sont
les chants les plus beaux je reconnais
d'immortels qui sont de pures sanglots
et jacques prévert a écrit dans paroles
ou dans l'histoire les chats désespérés
sont les chants du pied bot comme moi il
me semble me souvenir que celle fois de
musiciens des bus et des mousses et
[Applaudissements]
continue qui a dit qu on line qui a dit
l'humour est la politesse du désespoir
c'est le capitaine igloo non sa
capitaine
non c'est pour les bons dans les trucs
comme ça françoise littérature les
archives et politesse du désespoir
l'humour est la politesse surya bonaly
en 82 non après un double axel aux gens
c'est lui qui a dit ça aujourd'hui
savoir qui a dit vous pouvez détruire
tout ce qu'il vous plaira elle n'aura
qu'à ou six cabrel à la bravo les mecs
virils mais j'ai mieux aimé faire
utilisez vous souhaitez les musées pour
les bouquets au sénat et les cartes et
on reconnaît qu'après si la montée alors
j'ai cité la phrase en entier parce
qu'elle est très belle 1 vous pouvez
détruire tout ce qu'il vous plaira elle
n'aura qu'à ouvrir l'espace de ses bras
pour tout reconstruire hier si je suis
désolé est ce que je me permettent de
dire que c'est aussi beaucoup c'est
qu'il ya des chanteurs qui écrivent des
textes qui nous aura de la littérature
française qu'après hors saison et une
très belle fiction songe au sujet des
mélodies au sujet des textes est là je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce
qu'elle dit il ya de très très belles
chansons qui sont de pur chef-d'oeuvre
au niveau du texte
oui ça c'est la vérité et moi je vais
vous dire la parole ces paroles
d'évangile les paroles de des chansons
de léo ferré sont des chefs-d'oeuvre
bien sûr chef-d'oeuvre l'avantagent de
daniel prévost c'est qu'ils donnent du
contenu allait écrire à la sas et
formule 1 vous l'a plombé plus tard tu
es là pour çà laniel moi ça m'a beaucoup
plu l'histoire de mon amie la rose que
vous chantiez je suis désolé de vous
dire peut-être que ça vous plaît pas
mais c'est une très très jolie chanson
et vous l'avez très très bien chanter
maintenant donnez moi de l'argent je
continue
[Rires]
bien
alors vous avez déclaré françoise hardy
ce qui est passé ne reviendra plus une
phrase telle non mais une phrase non je
suis très fort tant la panis alors
n'attendez dont il ya un truc terrible à
dire que pour vous qui avait incarné
comme vous êtes la génération qui a
incarné l'adolescence quand on lit des
phrases comme ça puis plus on n'est pas
loin d'avoir le même âge vous dites il
ne me reste plus que 30 fois à voir
fleurir les lilas c'est vrai que con
quand on compte la vie en année on voit
fleurir les lilas ou autre chose c'est
ridicule même sans fois avoir bondi pas
jusqu'à 100 ans mais sans fois voir
fleurir l'insee réunion mais c'est vous
qui plombe l émission oui mais là
pouvait bien faire pousser des ailes aux
sons ploie de très bonne qualité
bravo moi je voulais faire sortir en
salles ou travailler sur françoise hardy
j'ai réfléchi pourquoi vous êtes un peu
comme on dit l'âme en peine
j'ai trouvé trois raisons la première
raison on va pas s'étendre là dessus on
est capricorne tous les deux si vous
êtes capricorne êtes saturnienne il n'y
a pas que vous moi je fais ça tu reviens
moi non mais juppé car je connais
capricorne ne sont pas saturés même nom
d'accord vous êtes anxieux angoissés
vous êtes ermite face à ces traits
capricorne ya un vous vivez dans un
bunker il paraît maintenant 16e
arrondissement en face à françoise hardy
quand on lui parle de meilleures
vacances qu'elle pourrait passer elle
dit ses seuls à paris au mois d'août
s'agit oui c'est vrai ou alors seul dans
encore s'enfermer dans ma chambre avec
40 bouquin grand plaisir les oliveaux là
encore mirlin non non non mais si oui
oui non mais c'est pour ça que j'ai pas
besoin de voyager
la première raison de votre agent de
voyages par l'esprit fait qu'ils
saturent viennent deuxième raison votre
grand mère
c'est vrai qu'entre ans mais elle nous a
pas aidés françoise non mais bien
entendu yves rooses et au dernier degré
mais nous sommes tous vous savez oui ma
grand mère était avec une poitrine
énorme et elle avait des jambes très
courte et donc elle a passé son temps à
me dire que j'étais affreuse devient
droit l'arbre c'est pour ça que je ne
vais pas imiter j'ai arrêté le
développement de ça
j'ai lui disait qu'elle avait un gros
ventre c'est pas sa grand-mère de même
un truc génial c'est qu'elle vous disait
elle vous parlez toujours des mecs avec
une espèce de thon autant d'étapes
l'hystérique votre grand-mère faut dire
des choses bon enfin c'était une autre
génération en génération qu'elle restait
toujours en parlant des mecs elle vous
par action de la chose la chose est
alors je me suis à une chanson de vous
que j'adore qui s'appelle swing low
précis vous vous dites mon mari m'a fait
la chose aujourd'hui c'est honteux
comment est-ce que jonas michel gabriel
yared des gens des artistes de cette
trempe ont pu se [ __ ] de moi de cette
phase mon mari m'a fait la chanson mais
tu me laisses effet ces magnifiques
cette chanson je m'efface swing au
pressing vous aimez pas c'est un
monument de la chanson france ah non
c'est vrai non je connaissais pas je
vais dire moi alors sérieusement fait le
seul couple gay qui durerait aussi
longtemps finalement yeah yeah yeahs
comment ça se fait à votre avis ça je
pense que c'est parce qu'on est
terriblement casanier on déteste la
nouveauté les gens nouveau tout ça est
ce que c'est pas parce que dd non mais
sérieusement est-ce que c'est pas parce
que dès le départ sérieusement parce que
j'essaye de trouver le bonheur comme
tout le monde en parlait que
malheureusement depuis un certain temps
là justement on est dans une certaine
pointe a fait j'essaie justement marche
oui je me dis que dutronc vous a imposé
un petit peu la même chose c'est-à-dire
que il habille toi sur des distances
vous marrer et on attend dans notre
couple
ça marche très bien mais vous marchez
tout le temps vous vous dites je devais
savoir pourquoi mon couple marche vous
marchez tout le temps nous arrêter la
page et vous monsieur prévost je suis
marié cinq fois
est ce que le est-ce que c'est pas ça
est-ce qu'une sérieusement est-ce que le
fait qu'il ait mis tout de suite des
distances image est ce que c'est parce
acquis à préserver votre bien sûr que
c'est une recette qui marche pour pour
certaines personnes bien sûr que le
couple est une affaire condamné plus ou
moins à l'avancé que la façon de le
faire durer le plus longtemps possible
c'est de ne pas être dans une
promiscuité trop importante
c'est pas trop focaliser sur l'autre
fissuré et mais c'est des lapalissades
aussi bon non non les gens qui savent
attendait les gens les gens et des pins
sur quoi est basée le couple il ya des
couples qui sont frères et soeurs il y
en a d'autres qui sont amants maîtresse
on adopte qui son père mais tout dépend
sur quoi ces bases et si on aime aussi
si c'est basé sur sur le désir c'est sûr
que il faut éviter la promiscuité voilà
ce qu'on vivait ensemble vous et vous
avez vécu ensemble ou vision spéciale du
spectre est ce que vous dédié à présent
vous avez vécu sa part a mis ton
vaguement de l'accord et puis pas mal de
chacun votre votre voilà ils ont chacun
un état c'est comme chez michel mango
d'accord on va abandonner on va avoir
donné votre coupe je suis désolé parce
que je pense qu'il ya plein de choses me
dit il ya plein de choses que vous
pouvez pas votre exemple apprendre à des
jeunes couples à plusieurs générations
je confierais j'espère que nous érigeons
à une stanis n'attendait vraiment mais
vous avez su préserver votre amour et ça
dure depuis longtemps sous genre tu
préserver un rôti de veau par an
[Applaudissements]
bon puisque c'est comme ça vous croyez
aux astres on va faire une interview
croyances on bouge quand le djing ont
peu bougé par le génial
[Musique]
y'a pas pascal bruckner je crois qu'il
arrive c'est bruner qui vient pascal
réception c'est bien je sais brumaire
qui vient il est bon dans ces bruckner
on va parler du bonheur justement moi je
sais c'est qu'on n'y arrive pas est ce
que vous voyez est ce que vous croyez à
l'amour oui bien c'est même ce qui est
plus important parce que tout ce qui va
mal dans le monde vient de gens qui dans
leur enfance
on était carencée en amour authentique
voilà parce qu'il ya plein de
falsification de l'amour même il ya des
tas de parents qui n'aiment pas leurs
enfants
enfin il croit qu'il est mais en fait
ils ne l'aiment pas et je vous croyez en
vous c'est fluctuant
je voyais en dieu
dieu c'est un mot mais mais ce qu'il ya
derrière ce mot oui je vous croyais au
hasard si nalement pas tant que ça pas
tant que ça est ce que vous croyez au
petit signe du destin par exemple
frédéricton raconter tout à l'heure son
rêve était sur un taxi avec samy naceri
cia pascal bruckner et non bruner dans
l'émission oui sinon est ce que vous
croyez aux mauvais esprits avec un sms
mais il ya des théories qui sont très
intéressantes qui veulent que que
certains êtres qui sont morts donc et
qui sont restés trop attaché au matériel
à la matière reste très proche de la
terre et sont assez néfaste
je sais pas ce que ça vaut un gardien je
ne sais pas je crois je crois qu'il ya
des forces invisibles qui nous qui
peut-être nous protège les guides et
aussi par
on est guidé par ce que l'on peut croire
à des choses sans rentrer dans des
tripes mystique ou quoi mais c'est aussi
ce qui nous fait ce qui nous fait
avancer tous les jours je sais que je
crois je crois aux gens qui par exemple
vous on vous ont aimé même s'ils sont
plus là et le fait de vous vous
continuez à les aimer ça vous fait
avancer donc je pense pas il me
regardant au moyen mais moi je continue
à aimer sur la je parle par exemple pour
une personne appréciée aujourd'hui vous
croyez à la télépathie ah oui je pense
qu'il peut y avoir effectivement
l'homéopathie ah oui les guesh patti j'y
crois aussi bon qu'est ce que vous
voulez là comme récompense pour avoir
bien répondu à toutes ses questions
voulait le triomphe romain la forêt vous
aimez la forêt marie laforêt non la
forêt partir dans la forêt fort et oui
vous voulez partir dans la forêt vous
avez fermé les yeux ça dépend si c'est
la forêt non c'est non pas du tout c'est
une forêt très calme c'est votre boulot
n'y a là rien chez vous je pense y avait
les yeux
est ce que tout le monde peut fermer les
yeux sur le plateau chez eux permet des
yeux tout le monde ferme les yeux fermés
les yeux on part en forêt
chez moi que chez moi
on dirait un viol
voilà c'était notre petite minute dans
la forêt ça vous a plu
voilà on va tous nous on n'est ce pas
monsieur prévost mais moi j'aime
beaucoup je sais bien la forêt oui j'ai
reconnu notre petit oiseau j'accueille
20 ans henry est venu
[Applaudissements]
henri bonsoir vous connaissez frédérique
santal kad et olivier françoise hardy
daniel prévost alors henri emmanuelli
dans le débat sur les stock options en
plus que les verts ou chevènement c'est
vous qui avait tenu laurent fabius en
échec non j'ai pas tenu des chèques j'ai
défendue mme jospin en mettrait en votre
faveur
et puis après on fait des compromis
c'est la vie c'est comme dans la vie de
couple vous êtes bienvenus vous pouvez
d'ailleurs si fabius se remplace un peu
au gouvernement dominique strauss kahn
vous vous remplacer un petit peu martine
aubry qui va briguer la mairie de lille
s'est elle a du charme je suis très
flatté parce que vous êtes un peu le
contrepoids vous êtes un peu le
contrepoids à fabius maintenant comme
aubry de l'été à strauss kahn
il ya des rôles comme ça dans la vie
daniel prévost il faut que ce soit le
méchant quoi voilà tout à l'heure il
faisait le petit canalis et moi je ne
mets jamais vous vous êtes le mec qui a
des convictions et qui les fait respecté
ce pas mal comme rôle je vais vous dire
moi je trouve pas ça très polie de dire
le mec s'est dit non mais j'ai trouvé
dans l'eau bien monsieur le mec je suis
marié aussi monsieur lemay bien en tous
les cas tout va bien pour vous mais au
remaniement vous avez été un petit peu
oublié écoutez je venais d'arriver mais
pas tout à la fois comme un peu le grand
oublié du remaniement ça c'est pay
m'abstiens presque donc vous avez fait
rire comme ça il sourit tout le temps
vous avez été réélu brillamment députés
réélus bris alors des plus tôt
les landais président de la commission
des finances à l'assemblée nationale et
puis c'est un peu une revanche
finalement sur ce que vous avez subi à
l'époque de l'affairé urba vous a été
inculpé pour complicité de trafic
d'influencé
deux ans d'inégibilité a un peu payé
pour les autres une à deux années sans
boulot c'est tout son boulot non c'est
juste dit pas à plein depuis ça m'a
donné l'occasion de faire des choses on
en parlait mais deux ans d'inégibilité
bon en même temps il a un peu payé pour
les autres parce que c'est vrai que on
s'est attaqué à un homme plutôt qu'à une
institution vous étiez trésorier du ps
c'est pour ça que vous avez payé pour
les autres quoi je vous laisse faire les
commentaires parce que moi j'avais
tellement fait ouais
puis c'est tellement envie de parler
d'autres dont on va parler d'autre chose
mais c'est important quand même non vous
êtes sacrifiés pour le parti c'est bien
j'aime pas le mot sacrifiée il ya eu un
contexte et puis trouve que j'étais là
je passais par là ouais les moments faut
pas passer par la cua ouais enfin quand
même ça force l'admiration tout le monde
l'a dit là il n'a pas balancé quoi le
mec qui déclare monsieur le mec pardon
il n'a pas balancé tu vas ramé a pas du
tout amélie je voterai bien vous êtes
vous n'êtes pas trop pour la nouvelle
économie vous vous êtes vous dit on est
un peu le nez dans la marijuana
boursière oui ben je suis pas ce que ça
veut dire la nouvelle économie
il ya des gens qui produisent il ya des
gens qui vendent il ya des gens qui
achètent il ya des échanges et celle
impression ça ça n'a pas beaucoup changé
quoi alors vas pas la même chose
heureusement ni les mêmes choses mais je
crois que ça fait partie des effets de
mode mais ça passera enfin tous les cas
pour vous ce qu'on peut dire pour vous
défie pour finir de vous définir le
social n'est pas un sous produit de
l'économie non je crois pas voilà donc
on pourrait dire que fabius c'est la
modernisation et vous vous êtes un peu
la redistribution
en tout cas moi je suis très attaché à
la redistribution c'est pour ça que je
suis engagé dans ce parti si ça devait
plus être le cas ça poserait quelques
problèmes comme si les socialistes
n'occupe pas qui ça n'occupera elle
reproche suffisamment de passage
occupaient l'année quelques jeux qui
persévèrent quand on vous dit que cette
archaïque ça vous énerve
au début ça m'énervait puis alors
maintenant ça me laisse de glace parce
que ce genre de généralités
tahar cailly qui ceci et cela c'est
comme quand on dit daniel prévost et les
bonbons ça lui fait plus rien il le sait
oui c'est vrai voilà la raison monsieur
emmanuel y est ce que votre vie à un
homme de goût tu vois il me signe dans
son discours c'est pas oublier
l'inspecteur des impôts - personne n'a
oublié est ce que votre vieux différend
avec laurent fabius viendrait pas de vos
origines et c'est pas de la même classe
sociale au départ non écoutez je crois
que on a eu des différentes politiques
mais moi j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour
laurent fabius que je respecte que j'ai
appris d'ailleurs vous connaissez plus
longtemps oui depuis plus de vingt ans
donc je les aime bien maintenant alors
je veux pas trop en rajouter non plus
bas on va dire il en fait trop ouais et
lui-même savall surprendre il va parler
des questions mais bon moi j'ai pas
d'animosité jeu plutôt du respect pour
lui comment faire quand je parle par
exemple de deux classes sociales vous
vos parents c'était vraiment des
croyants communiste pour le communisme
c'est une espèce de religion votre père
était militant cgt et s'est fait virer
pour ça d'ailleurs
il est devenu artisan électricien et il
est mort en réparant un ligne quoi sur
un clocher perception a cloché ça c'est
terrible ça pas militant oui surtout
pour vous qui êtes un bouffeur de curé
quand même marrant c'est un signe du
seigneur alors et c'est complet le père
d'emmanuelli bouffeurs de curés mort en
réparant un clocher oui et d'ailleurs en
78 a déclaré à l'assemblée nationale à
bas la calotte à ces bouffeurs de curés
qu'il y avait une histoire
il y avait une discussion qui n'en
finissait pas j'avais déclaré que je
venais d'arriver
j'étais tout jeune ouais c'est pas comme
maintenant kwh est maintenant vous iriez
plus à bas la calotte
non parce que je pense que plus sujet et
ce peu changé je peux sujet du tabac la
cula donc oui c'était très mal c'est
paradoxal au riz manioc dit pas ce que
vous avez fait baptiser vos enfants les
deux oui oui parce que la mecque et
bouffeurs de curés c'est bizarre quand
même nom mais parce que moi je sais que
je considère qu'ils doivent être en
situation dans une cité dans une
civilisation judéo-chrétienne mon frère
n'avait pas fait et sa fille ensuite lui
a reproché alors elle a fait une
fixation sur le fait qu était pas
baptisé dont j'ai dit les miens ne font
pas de six mois voilà la mère d'henri
emmanuelli on a relaté surnommé 14
juillet donc c'est quand même
cain qui étaient plutôt réputés et ta
soeur
j'en ai ras glace c'est une émission
familiale famille
absolument vous êtes un mec courageux
parce qu'en 63 vous débarquez à paris à
sciences po et vous repartez trois ans
dans le béarn quand votre mère est
malade vous repartez trois ans pour vous
occuper d'elle l'offre de vie votre
carrière à faire des ti à paris et vous
repartez oui mais ça c'est la vie on n'a
pas toujours le choix on s'occupe des
siens quand même assez le minimum main
c'est bien il me semble qu'on ne trouve
pas que ce soit un exploit quand vous
revenez donc à paris après vous rentrez
dans une banque
alors là il ya des points communs avec
findus bizarrement parce que vous avez
ça en commun c'est à dire que vous en 72
assez incroyable aussi c'est comme le
fait d'avoir fait baptiser vos enfants
en 72 vous entrez chez rothschild henri
emmanuelli chez rothschild à la banque
rothschild
oui c'est énorme quand on croyable bah
oui on savait pas en vérité monsieur
découvrait quelque chose de terrible
ensuite d'abord entré dans une banque
qui s'appelait le manque de vision
parisienne une banque pour tester banque
d'affaires et ensuite je suis chez la
compagnie financière edmond de
rothschild c'est insensé ça a pas du
tout j'étais très bien
72 68 73
deux ans plus tard j'ai rentré dans une
charcuterie oui on a dû d'ailleurs à peu
près sorti la même année comme pompidou
quand même pompidou la beauté chez
rothschild cie j l'ofce le coup chez
l'autre c'est commode parce qu'il ya des
gens qui envoyait des lettres quand je
milite et un à la banque rothschild à
bon compte il dit mon co n'est pas
celui-là
ah oui ça m'a sauvé ça m'a aidé alors
finalement henri emmanuelli quand le
wall street journal dit on peut toujours
compter sur les socialistes pour nous
faire rire quand il parle d'économie
vous fait rire parce que vous la
connaissez l'économie vous avez bossé
chez bon ça fait partie des généralités
et les préjugés
je pense qu'un aussi grand journal
devrait avoir un peu plus de finesse
dans l'analyse quoi mais bon c'est pas
grave
un effort de leur point de vue ils sont
là pour ça faut bien qu'ils faut bien
qu'ils gagnent leur vie est il des
moments marrant quand vous étiez dans la
banque passé des mecs qui venait bouffer
dans la salle à manger de la banque et
qui disait ici au moins on peut parler
c'est pas comme dans les banques
nationalisées qui sont truffés de
socialisme teslas moi se souvient de sa
wii oui j'ai même organisé à l'époque
quelques rendez vous entre des
responsables du parti et puis des gens
pour citer dans une banque on l'embêté
pas me laisser faire ce que je voulais
quand même
parallèlement à ça un pack qu'à la
conversation serait aussi sérieuse moi
mais ça dépend c'est ce qui fait le
charme de cette émission c'est qu'on
peut dire des grosses conneries puis de
temps en temps moi oui si vous avez une
bonne comme riz la plage surtout parce
que là c'est en train de se plonger
depuis qu'on est arrivé en même temps
non mais il est préparé pour rigoler
mais huit arrivées bien elle son père
sur le clocher penché sur vous en même
temps vous êtes chez rothschild vous
rencontrer françois mitterrand la même
année à peu près quatre mois soit zardi
vous progressez dans les rails et cela
aurait été différent
ballet pendant l'été mais là jusqu'à sa
démission ce tournoi
mais est extrêmement pour toi et bien
élevé mais là il peut plus y tient plus
vivace avait rien pourquoi avatar et et
on sort ça vas y toi grand bien pas peur
continue avec monsieur manuel et oui je
traite que j'aimerais manger ont gelé
très j'ai appelé henri je le connais
produits tous après ça je le rencontre
suis si énervé un corps et mes amis et
moi je vous connais moi moi c'est tout à
fait gentil moi je vous adhériez
homeaway commerçants oui donc
effectivement vous montez au parti
socialiste à l'époque où vous êtes
inculpés dans cette affaire
urbas la sphère des strates pourquoi les
gens du parti vous ont pas soutenu vont
laisser un petit peu ils sont pas levés
comme un seul homme on peut dire quoi
bon on peut pas donc on peut pas dire ça
comme ça non plus je crois qu'ils ont
ils ont fait ce qu'ils avaient à faire
et ce qu'ils croyaient devoir faire ne
s'était pas des circonstances facile
nous leur en voulais pas mais non
écoutez les socialistes ils sont comme
ils sont humains il appartient au genre
humain non qu'ils ont les qualités et
les défauts vous savez ce que c'est oui
c'est pas une race à part vous a été
vraiment déprimé à l'époque vous allez
non non vraiment pas mon nom c'était dur
mais déprimé non je ne déprime pas
facilement justement alors on en arrive
à votre livre
si tu avais interdit de chez ramsay zoom
zoom mon garçon
dieffenthal valeur des fantasmes je ne
crois pas j'ai passé bravo non moi je
viens ici pour savoir s il est vraiment
c'est ce qu'a lieu dans toutes les
missions chez bouquins c'est pas ça un
tract politique vous allez faire
d'ailleurs de bouquins politique sur
l'europe quelques années c'est pas une
biographie de dôme historique de
personnages historiques comme font tous
les tous les hommes politiques qui font
tout ça sarkozy a fait mandel bo a fait
henri iv ses gains à pôle emploi c'est
pas ça du tout c'est un roman mais là où
c'est un tout petit peu tôt du graphique
quand même c'est un homme foudroyé par
un drame personnel et qui est pris au
piège de l'appareil judiciaire
enfin s'il fallait que je trouve une
situation un peu paroxystique pour aller
au bout de certaines réflexions et donc
j'ai pensé qu'au passage je pouvais
faire d'une pierre deux coups mais ce
n'était pas l'objectif
en réalité dans le livre est un homme
qui fit sa vie parce qu'il s'est
toujours un peu son petit décalé à
l'écart il veut savoir pourquoi
arrivé à un certain moment il sort
pourquoi et à ce moment là
retournant chez un demi frère il est
pris dans un imbroglio où il est pris
dans ce cas c'est sûr c'est un homme qui
fit qui fit part et après le décès de sa
femme enceinte et une musicienne dans un
accident il se réfugie dans les pyrénées
gers en 2000 frère cadet et là il est
mêlé à une affaire c'est ça va faire
deux terroristes basques
il ya un policier des rg qui tue est
donc celle allons l'engrenage voilà qui
va conduire des gens en prison en
préventive et pour moi c'était
l'occasion cette prison était évidemment
l'endroit où on réfléchit avec un peu
plus d'épaisseur des densités que dans
la vie normale mais pour moi le sujet du
livre c'était ça c'était la réflexion du
bonhomme c'est pas c'est pas la justice
la justice j'en parle mais pour dire
grosso modo que la société actuelle lui
assigne un rôle difficile qui est un
petit peu situé entre le sacré et ce qui
ne l'est pas c'est à dire la
responsabilité de dire le biel mal ce
qui est une responsabilité énorme
et qu'elle le fait parce que la société
de la sinne ce rôle et ce qui est
paradoxal d'ailleurs c'est combien sim
ce rôle et qu'en même temps on lui
reproche de le tenir
donc je vous crois que je traite savez
que vous n'êtes pas attendre aussi pour
la pour la presse aussi c'est un peu
plus graphique page 145 vous dit
la presse a fait le maximum pour noircir
le tableau comme vous aviez dit dans un
journal les journalistes sont les
pigistes des juges sur les journalistes
suite à frapper parce qu'on fait la
remarque en fait je dis rien
d'extraordinaire je je je dis simplement
le bonhomme qui découvre les médias et
qui s'aperçoit que cette affaire qu'il
croyait privée devient public à ce
moment là ils vont se dérouler un
feuilleton sous ses yeux
mais c'est ce qui arrive tous les jours
à tous ceux qui sont pris sous les feux
de l'actualité pour pour quelle que soit
la raison d'ailleurs je pense qu'ils ont
à peu près tout la même réaction me
semble-t-il visite le plus terrible dans
l'innocence bafouée
ça aussi c'est quelque chose qui est
arrivé c'est qu'on finit par se sentir
coupable je pense effectivement que tous
ceux qui ont regardé de près comment se
passer certaines situations y compris
les plus tragiques dans le soin ont tous
dit qu'à un moment donné les gens qu'on
met en situation de culpabilité
finissent par se sentir un peu coupable
tout simplement parce qu'il faut qu'il
trouve une raison à cette situation là
et qu'ils ont le choix entre se sentir
un peu coupable ou bien l'absurdité la
gratuité alors petit à petit bascule
dans ce syndrome de stockholm c'est dire
que voilà la victime finit par un verbe
haut voila voila et le jeu propre plutôt
les bourreaux connaissent ce genre de
perversion et c'est là c'est ce que je
fais 10 ans sert son serveur bien ça
t'incite à elles interdites sécher rams
et c'est henri emmanuelli
henri emmanuelli maintenant on va faire
un exercice un petit peu compliqué
souvent les hommes politiques qui
arrivent mieux que les autres chez pas
pourquoi ça s'appelle l'interview
mensonges et ont peu bougé dans le
jingle
[Musique]
c'est l'habitude on peut pas bouger mais
ce soir exceptionnellement comme l'avait
prévost on était sûr de pas arrivé à le
tenir donc on a changé la règle du jeu
tout à l'heure je veux lui faire avaler
un bouquin way a volontiers oui ça fait
six fois qu'il dit prévenu monsieur
prévost alors que je dis monsieur
prévost je suis marqué durant ce que je
veux continuer l'émission sans qu'ils se
mettent bien dans la tête
allez attention pas de violence il vous
henri emmanuelli donc vous mentez 1
est ce que ça vous choque que des gens
qui ont bénéficié de l'école en france
des soins dans les hôpitaux
dès qu'il gagne un peu d'argent il
quitte la france pour aller vivre en
angleterre et est payé leurs impôts
l'angleterre ça ne me choque pas est ce
que vous comprenez que des gens qui
travaillent dans le froid avec des
masses dans des usines de poissons
surgelés demande à travailler 35 heures
vous trouvez ça normal vous non je
trouve pas ça normal
est ce que vous êtes choqué par le fait
par exemple que la compagnie
d'assurances axa double les primes
d'assurance pour les handicapés à la
raison à la région
total qui utilisent des bateaux pourri
mais pas cher monsieur le business après
tout où il faut déjà faire quoi pour 19
sont dans leur job
vous êtes d'accord vous que les prêts
dans les bibliothèques municipales
soient payants absolument c'est cher
auteur que deviendrait-il autrement
c'est pas grave qui soit pas lui pourvu
qu'ils soient bien payés c'est
scandaleux quand même que vous trouvez
pas donc les musées soit gratuit parce
que finalement c'est le contribuable qui
paye et puis je trouve ça permet pas aux
gens d'apprécier à leur juste valeur les
étapes que les tableaux qu'on leur
montre il faut quand même donner un peu
de soi même n'est ce pas serait pas que
fabius était un peu trop à gauche quand
même si
[Rires]
à part ça on va passer aux femmes
oui facile vous êtes atteint par le
démon de midi
oui oui c'est l'interview mensonger mais
oui oui vous êtes toujours avec l'abbé
changistes oui vous savez parce que
alors est ce que vous savez que deux
plus deux à déménager ou gipi ya
longtemps c'est boulevard edgar quinet
manon a revu je connais le boulevard je
connais patiner mais je trouverais quand
même vous êtes quoi rouler vous avez de
quoi rouler un pétard évidemment pétards
en début de soirée après je passe à
autre chose comme avec mes choix que
vous aviez arrêté la coca aurait aimé
lui ni non non non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci on rallume j'accueille maintenant
mathilda may
[Applaudissements]
mathilda may bonsoir vous connaissez
tous le monde
monsieur kalt oui c'est une spéciale
très bien vous avez déclaré mathilda may
les interviews à la télévision me
paralyse parce que j'ai pas de support à
travers lequel m'exprimer mais je vous
tiens à vous dire que c'est tout à fait
naturel
on sait très bien que les acteurs
existent à travers un personnage donc
oui enfin on peut exister autrement qu'à
travers un personnage mais dans un
contexte qui met davantage en confiance
oui bien on va faire un peu de promo
françoise génial c'est aller un bracelet
vous faites pareil le foufou vendredi
dans la commune chinois on est finie
nationale vous trouvez ça pas bien de le
faire
oui forêt c'est ça specter deuxième
pouvant tirer prétexte cheval bien alors
vous êtes magnifique dans le film de
arcady qui s'appelle là bas mon pays
avec antoine de caunes s'est passé vous
fait que passer mais suffisamment pour
qu'on vous ait remarqué sous va bien le
style 60 en plus et vous devez spa avec
votre fiancée qui est devenu puis alors
vous faites alors voir tout ce que vous
faites mais vous faites un participé au
clip pour la fête du cinéma
on a fait du cinéma je dis à nos amis
téléspectateurs c'est du 25 au 27 juin
sa 16e édition
donc il ya un petit clip qui a été fait
comme ça pour promouvoir cette fête et
on va le voir tout de suite
elle a fait des bacs à chaque doigt des
poignets et puis ajouté
avec une fois ici
mont joli
m
d
bah
king
bach
[Musique]
tous ces cols et quand tout serait
reconnue pour koster
on se repère 9
ton s'est retrouvé quand on s'est
réchauffé pour toi si ses palais
[Musique]
m
tous
et
la souris
la fête du cinéma le tourbillon la
chanson du film jules et jim
mais c'est un remix ça bon il ya le film
marque à dix à la fête du cinéma il ya
un téléfilm sur france 2 en 2 pas deux
fois 90 minutes avec nils tavernier ça
passe quand ça passera à la rentrée je
sais pas exactement quand un film en
deux parties
c'est quoi l'histoire c'est l'histoire
d'un médecin urgentiste qui travaillent
ou samu qui va se retrouver face à des
situations très très difficile
succession d'épreuves une sorte de
descente aux enfers on va dire j'ai eu
beaucoup de succès à un moment j'ai eu
un passage à vide et aujourd'hui on a le
sentiment que vous vous reprenez le
dessus une espèce de sentiment de
renaissance
vous dites d'ailleurs je suis tellement
mieux dans ma peau aujourd'hui qu'à 25
ans c'est vrai on peut dire on peut
parler d'un passage à vide sur le plan
professionnel mais sur le plan de ma vie
non non je veux parler moi je parle
jamais bien sûr mais c'était une chose
oui je sais pas quel âge as tu les auras
pas 25 ans est la plus 25 ans n'ont donc
j'ai
tout et tout a un sens et tout est
bénéfique si on sait tirer parti de
toutes les situations enfin en tout cas
cette distance qui a été prise par
rapport au cinéma un moment donné a été
très utile puisque aujourd'hui je crois
j'ai apprécié en tout cas je ne la
prennent pas le métier de la même
manière et que sais tu ce recul a été
tout à fait bénéfique dans tous les cas
de lait sentiment d'avoir surmonté vos
difficultés
vous avez mieux à vous accepter par
exemple je ne crois j'y travaille
vous avez plus confiance en vous vous
sentez d'alsace de bonheur oui je pense
que c'est si tant est que oui c'est un
long travail non je me parcourt u2
l'actrice n'a pas encore prouvé ce dont
elle était capable
oui pensez que votre carrière devant
vous je pense je pense que en fait j'ai
commencé très tôt que j'ai peut-être pas
réalisé à l'époque vraiment la chance
que j'avais j'ai peut-être pas su tirer
parti de des choix que j'avais à
l'époque je me suis retrouvé assez
rapidement avec beaucoup de choix
j'ai peut-être pas fait les bons
compte tenu de la situation à quel
j'étais comme ça de j'avais un petit peu
peur que ça s'arrête donc j'étais un peu
motivés par il semble donc oui tous les
films parce qu'en fait vous avez peur ça
convient à tous j'avais peur que ça
s'arrête et j'ai tout fait certainement
des choix qui ont peut-être nui à mon
épanouissement d'actrice et finalement
ce qui s'est passé m'a dit ah c'est que
j'ai été beaucoup plus connu une
certaine époque pour les couvertures de
magazines que pour les pour les films
que vous vous faisiez pour la simple et
bonne raison que j'ai pas été vraiment
dans un succès populaire
j'ai pas fait un film qui vient un vrai
succès populaire comme 37 doux
donc c'est vrai qu'on m'a plus vu en
couverture de magazines que dans les
salles et c'est à mon avis l'image qu'on
retient d'aujourd'hui plus l'âge arrêté
de photos avec les médias se sont un
petit peu entiché de la fille avec la
frange les créoles les lèvres rouges
l'engouement médiatique qui est à
relativement fréquent pour une fille
jeunes qui arrivent l'attrait de la
nouveauté tout ça les modes et puis mais
je les ai laissé faire je n'accuse
personne monsieur roch s'avoue un peu
les chasseurs membres ont choisi oui oui
et puis c'est vrai que j'avais fait une
petite série de photos comme ça je
pensais pas que ça allait avoir cette je
me souviens je me suis prêtée au jeu de
la pin up et cela a nui à mon image en
c'est vrai vous plus on essaie que
symbole mais on est crédible en tant qu'
en tant qu'actrice et puis les
réalisateurs bayrou choisisse pas pour
pour certains rôles à ce moment là enfin
sex symbol sait jamais une idée ça pas
été une idée à moi c'est votre argent
qui avait très envie de me présenter
comme ça puis je trouve que c'est ce qui
a été dit pourquoi pas en tout cas je ne
pense si je continue de penser
aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas
incompatible avec ce qu'on peut avoir
exprimé en tant qu'actrice en même temps
vous êtes quand même très coquette vrai
que j'ai pas devenu sex-symbol par
hasard vous avez commencé à vous
maquiller à l'âge d'un ça me flatte très
tôt oui beaucoup trop mon premier
mascara 11 ans comme moi
vous avez un vrai problème avec le avec
le maquillage c'est à dire c'est une
véritable obsession chez vous vous dites
je suis sûr que le boulanger m'a jamais
vu pas maquillée même mon boulanger m'a
jamais fait un temps plus maintenant
plus du tourisme et bien sûr mais
d'affaires par rapport à ça un peu cher
mais c'est vrai que très jeune j'ai
beaucoup maquiller cacher une façon de
se masquer oui d'ailleurs j'appréhende
et mon métier comme ça j'approchais
comme ça sert que je me servais des
rôles pour me cacher et en fait
aujourd'hui ce serait l'inversé vous dit
tiens si je m'étais boutabout tout le
temps que j'ai passé à me maquiller
je pourrais vivre une autre c'est pareil
est ce que cette volonté d'aller vers la
de vous de vous cacher sarthe est pas
aussi parce que vous avez eu une enfance
pas très pas très heureuse mais j'ai pas
eu une enfance heureuse et j'ai trop
appris à me taire oui mais alors ça
c'est une sorte d'éducation parallèle
que j'ai eues en dehors de celles des
parents qui étaient celles de la danse
classique du les parents d'abord votre
père qui est je passe ici les gens le
savent mais c'est un auteur dramatique
et c'est connu c'est victor haïm qui a
eu de très bonnes pièces votre mère
était dans l'ex danseuse étoile dans des
bals et exempts ce dont les balais
scandinaves et votre père a eu beaucoup
de critiques dont il a beaucoup souffert
des critiques qu'il a eu en fait c'est
difficile et auteur de faire ce métier
oui et votre mère alors elle vous disait
un truc terrible elle disait c'est un
peu comme la grand mère de françoise
hardy
on n'en parle plus elle a dit oui
votre mère vous disais vaut mieux se
taire et laisser croire aux autres qu'on
est bêtes plutôt que de parler de
montrer qu'on l'ait vraiment c'est
terrifiant l'agencé
c'était de l'humour mais c'est vrai que
c'est pas extrêmement épanouissant vous
ai fait de la danse et c'est un succès
militaire la danse cessé il ya une
tradition qui perdure
peut-être comme dans le milieu de
l'équitation il ya une sorte de
hiérarchie et de pouvoir qui est pris
par les professeurs avec une sorte d'
une forme de tyrannie
qui se traduit par l'humiliation des
élèves et des terrasses j'ai connu c'est
vrai c'est une éducation parallèle des
premières choses qu'on apprend quand on
est danseur c'est de se taire
donc c'est difficile de s'épanouir quand
on est enfant c était un peu brimer ton
petit quoi par la danse par vous
échangez de déchets voulu changer de
prénom si ça c'est très bizarre dire que
un moment vous avez refusé votre prénom
ça aussi c'est étrange je pense pas que
j'ai refusé je pense que j'ai questionné
sur mon identité et que ça a été compris
comme vous et à vos parents je veux
changer de prénom vous attendez à ce
qu'ils vous disent non ils vous disent
oui et vous changé et c'est en fait les
papiers tout oui enfin à l'époque je ne
suis pas en âge de m'en occuper mais
c'est pour çà se laisser faire sauf que
karine ice est tout aussi impressionnant
quand vous étiez petit donzy de la danse
vous étiez vous rêviez de d'opéra mais
en fait c'est très compliqué des mille
candidats il avait dit ce qui était qui
était choisi chaque année est un des
pires souvenirs de votre vie c'est qu'on
était dans la cour derrière l'opéra vous
attendiez les résultats j'ai un
sentiment d'échec profondes comme si ma
vie entière s'écroulait ce moment là
j'étais pas rester paviet j'ai vu avoir
10 ans mais j'avais un sentiment d'échec
au niveau de vie était finie chaque
année quand vous étiez pas prise dans
l'est dans les disques durs
oui c'était vraiment un vrai drame alors
je suis rentré au bout du compte
heureusement oui heureusement que j'ai
pas été plus jamais rendre à l'opéra
mais j'ai quand même eu le premier prix
du conservatoire de danse de paris est
là myriam bruch est une ex star lettres
d'hollywood en fait qu il tenu à gens
qui vous avez dit à l'âge de 10 ans oui
m'avait vu comme ça une générale
mon père dit soit tu sais quand tu fais
du cinéma c'est un gars que j'ai vu sauf
qu'un jour elle vous a vraiment fait
faire du oui je peux faire des essais
j'y suis allé un petit peu pour lui
faire plaisir moi j'étais danseuse était
pas question à l'époque que je change de
voie et donc je suis allé je parlais pas
amélioré à l'époque donc j'avais appris
phonétiquement un texte en anglais je
comprenais pas ce que je disais on
disait il faut il cherche une blonde les
e-bonds et puis ça a marché
et là j'ai goûté à quelque chose
évidemment de très le très séduisant de
très gratifiant parce que je me suis
retrouvé tout de suite sur un tournage
sans avoir prévenu est distrait avec une
caméra à bois vas-y à voir j'ai
incroyablement un cadreur entre les gens
mais c'est un par la cie entre monsieur
et massy et la malchance pour les nôtres
non mais c'est incroyable de faire des
trucs pas te demander l'autorisation
non message royal canin lève toi
lève toi et marche est devenu
franchement ce jour j'ai compté un but
c'est après que ça je pourrais le passé
un polar passé ce truc-là espère
continuer mathilde a continué sans moi
matilda non le le sou je comprends bien
tu es sûrement pas michel blanc vous
propose marche à l'ombre
c'est sophie duez qui finit par le faire
lui regrette un peu de ne pas vous avoir
eu la preuve c'est que l'héroïne
s'appelle mathilde c'est quand même un
nomade
non c'est parce qu'il avait écrit pour
moi donc on va regarder ce nom comme
c'était pas pourquoi vous l'avez pas
fait parce que j'avais été choisi pour
un film un tournage films américains qui
se tournait à londres et puis j c'était
en même temps pourquoi que sa constance
oui c'est ça fait partie c'est peut-être
mon seul regret je vous a pas empêché en
88 départ le césar du meilleur espoir
féminin en 89 de cléon romy schneider
puis voilà quoi et puis tant parce ça
vous a pas l'histoire des magazines en
parlait à l'instant décevants des
magazins effet beaucoup de couvertures
ne vous a pas gêné de faire la promotion
de certains films présentés avec gérard
darmon un moment alors vous étiez déjà
plus ensemble d'aller dans les magazines
posé ensemble ce n'est pas gênant
d'abord on n'était pas plus ensemble
ensuite on
il s'agissait d'un film on était un
couple et une histoire d'amour c'est la
monteuse et on a parlé ensemble de ce
film qu'on a défendu c'est vrai qu'elle
va y avoir des parallèles faire notre
vie privée est filmé qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire ce film avait besoin qu'on
parle de lui c'est un petit budget et
certainement pas beaucoup de salles on
pouvait pas sous prétexte que c'était
une situation un peu délicate et on a
essayé de
alors pensé à une très mauvaise nouvelle
je dis aime tous nos amis de
téléspectateurs mathilda may et marié
c'est pour moi une très bonne nouvelle
on sent quand même je m'étais alors
comme vous avez eue dans votre vidéo et
des barbes faire une interview à peine
dames et ont peu bougé dans le jingle
[Musique]
vous connaissez notre avis open down
j'en ai entendu parler
la pire que celle évaluée lit
l'interview mensonge
oui ça champagne ça c'est difficile
interview vincent jeanne surtout vous
qui êtes un type tellement honnête
emmène moi qui ment jamais vous avez dû
avoir du mal c'est la première fois de
votre vie je suis surpris pas tellement
bien mathilda may qu'est ce que vous
préférez en vous
mes pieds il faut les montrer personnes
ont manifesté
d'accord dès que j'ai l'occasion dans un
film j'exhibe le mage et ccoo qu'est ce
que vous détestez en vous les mains qui
sont proches des mains d'hommes
tu vois je l'admets mais les asayesh
daniel détends toi si j'étais correct
non parce que j'avais dit moi je veux
pas de oui mais c'est une vérité c'est
j'ai rien dit j'ai pas fait la tête
ma mère s'est très bien c'est une
émission qui vole très haut le plus
grand moment de votre vie
jusqu'à maintenant la naissance de mes
enfants
le pire les ruptures en fatigue ce qui
vous plaît le plus dans la vie les
enfants parce que les miens les enfants
passionne
s'il vous plaît de moi le moustique mais
ça va revenir les moustiques du domicile
et à quel endroit vous voudriez vous
étiez pas ici maintenant dans les bras
de mon âme on vous a pas photo et quel
est l'endroit fauquet les langages et et
il est heureux d être dans un endroit où
il fait très froid
ouais bah c'est pas le cas ici alors
qu'est-ce qui vous aide à dormir le soir
on a compris ce qu'est ce qui vous
empêche de dormir les questions quel
genre de mec me fait le plus fantasmer
les miens et le moins il y en a beaucoup
la plupart away et je fantasme ne peut
sur les mains il a dû prouver qu est ce
que vous avez de plus sexy en vous à
votre avis c'est pas à moi de le dire
henry
à cette impulsion et je ne sais pas
pourquoi compte tenu de la réponse
précédente
oui oui vous savez que vous avez aucun
espoir donc je ne vois pas où vous dites
voilà boulet toute la france et par
daniel son livre qui lui plaît mais en
même temps un nom mais je comprends ça
d'ailleurs daniel qu'est ce que la le
plus sexy en elle mathilde chiffre
jamais vu et je cite la butte où la
norme est sérieusement par owni les
bêtises mais elle est jolie comme tout
homme charmant moi c'est moi ce que dira
tout elle est jolie comme tout vous me
posez la question je voudrais vous
qu'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant on
va rallumer à est ensemble
non et on va voir on va voir un sketch
de daniel prévost jutra très bien bravo
je voudrais je voudrais vous faire mes
excuses
mes plus sincères excuses vous êtes là
devant moi
confiant dans mes propos à l'écouté du
moindre mot du moins de jeux de mots de
la moi d'incongruités du moindre qu'au
cas là de la plus petite envolée lyrique
la plus délicieuse images poétiques qui
pourrait sortir de mes lèvres ou bien au
relais et je m'aperçois avec effroi avec
terreur avec l'horreur d'un état de
stupéfaction qui veut paralyser me donne
des sueurs froides et un vertige tels
que je ne tiens plus sur mes jambes dans
le coup est rude pour moi je m'aperçois
que je ne vous ai pas encore parlé du
cul
non je ne vous ai pas parlé de cul comme
on fait dans un one-man-show normale et
j'ai violemment de moi je vous prie de
le voir chagrin m'envahit à l'idée que
vous avez payé votre place que vous êtes
déplacé peut-être de très loin d'une
banlieue pourrie vous avez pris le métro
que vous avez changé trois fois grave
que vous vous êtes parfumé que vous
pouvez le parfum vous madame blanca et
vous monsieur blanc coeur que vous vous
réjouissiez l'idée de venir me voir
chérie on va bien se marrer avec frémaux
peut-être qu'on va peut-être qu'il va
lui raconter des histoires dégueulasse
comme l'autre jour on a été voir c'est
bien toi qui s'appelle déjà mais je me
souviens plus de son nom mais si tu te
c'est bien celui qui nous raconter des
histoires de merde
l'écurie a tellement de tapisser dans ta
culotte
je vous prie d'accepter cher public mes
excuses les plus vives pour l'obliger
commis j'ai honte de ne pas vous avoir
parlé de bide de coutume daniel vraiment
cet extrait de la cassette décollage
immédiat je mens rea sens bien
voilà alors maintenant on va voir je
dirais que c'est une profession de foi
ce que j'ai fait je te remercie de
l'avoir passé ça me fait plaisir c'est
la seule compliment que je te ferai ce
soir c'est vraiment ça qui me fait
plaisir c'est une surprise de rien de
rien c'est totalement gratuite on sera
pas un rond mais ça m'a fait plaisir
mais ça allait je m'en vais pourquoi tu
vas voir la lie à nous alors il ya un
sketch de kad et olivier qui va je
voulais voir
non c'est juste un verre sévère on va
parler d'un truc on n'a pas l'équipe de
faire de la réclame la publicité mais ce
week-end avec olivier nous sommes allés
visiter la france miniature away la
france monsieur à l'avant mais nature
uta où tu t'es l'impression d'être un
géant s'est tu marches mener des vies
des tout savoir tout milliers de paris
au milieu de plein d'autres villes tu
peux visiter le château de chambord
c'est super intéressant tu as fait un
truc là la forêt de fontainebleau et du
manque d'intérêt du monologue de kad et
olivier comédie vous propose une leçon
de bricolage bonjour aujourd'hui nous
allons apprendre ensemble à fabriquer
une quête en contreplaqué voici la
première étape d calquer le modèle à
l'aide d'un papier calque et d'un crayon
taille 53 vous allez dès calquer le
modèle de votre choix
mais attention pensez à bien appuyé en
décalquant sur les contours de la
quéquette et des boules voilà vous avez
votre modèle passons maintenant à la
deuxième étape le calque âge sur la
planche
prenez votre calq et déposez-les sur la
planche de contreplaqué
il ne vous reste plus qu'à repasser avec
votre crayon sur les contours de la
quéquette et des boules vous avez
bientôt terminé passons à l'étape numéro
3 la découpe de la quéquette avec votre
psy sauteuse découpées soigneusement les
contours de votre dessin
faites attention de ne pas vous couper
voilà il vous reste maintenant à prendre
du papier de verre numéro 74 pour penser
et biaisé les côtés de la quéquette sans
oublier bien sûr le dessous des
bouboules dernière étape la touche
finale avec votre stylo découpé et
dessiner le gland et enfin tout en haut
le trou du pipi voilà en moins de 15
minutes
vous avez fabriqué cette superbe
quéquette en contreplaqué la semaine
prochaine nous fabriquerons ensemble une
chatte en polystyrène au revoir
[Applaudissements]
via le point et il ya le contrepoint
bien alors maintenant je vous faire une
interview à tous les tous répond ça
s'appelle l'interview casse-couilles
justement alors voilà la question
pour être sensé avec françoise hardy
nout à fond ah oui parce qu'en ce moment
tout le monde prépare à part d'acs en
salle c'est le mois de mai voilà
l'interview casse-couilles voilà la
question est ce que dit
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce que vous faites pour les
vacances lesquels d'été d'été ben je
voulais dit tout à l'heure je m'enferme
dans une chambre et 40 kg corse encore
quand même encore son meilleur oui en
corse probablement n'oublierez pas le
miel de la présence de monsieur m'a dit
je vais chercher une maison dans les
landes
on est venu ici
dans les landes non parce que dans les
landes moi si je prends des vacances
dans les landes c'est pas des vacances
donc j'ai serré de sans doute d'aller
voir mon fils aux antilles d'accord
daniel prévost interview casque
qu'ils me posent la question c'est moi
l'intermédiaire de mes avis david et
johnatan kosdaq est oui bah voila je
vous réponde un truc est totalement
inintéressant je vais partir en vacances
10 jours effectivement voilà pour la bas
où tu veux aussi casse cou quand il est
question sont un casse cou il sans casse
couille aussi c'est normal ça démesuré
ennuyé de dire dans les landes
voilà dans l'aisne davantage me lancer
dans les landes ya plus de pain il ya
beaucoup de pain il ya beau y ait
d'abord l'acte formidable ça c'est très
bien c'est un type sur le cube vous
pouvez tous venir d'ailleurs ah oui
c'est grand chez vous c'est grand on va
toucher emmanueli cet été frédéric
diefenthal que j
jeudi dans les landes bien mathilda may
ski
avant les vacances mais je comprends
maintenant je cherchais une idée donc
cherché une idée vieille pas d'idées
pour les vacances non dans les landes
accord cadre
[Musique]
depuis dix ans au mois de juillet center
parcs est moins goûteux voix libye libye
en belgique voilà le secret c'est quand
même normal aux yeux
tu fais un détour dans les landes aussi
chez monsieur mairie à montfort en
chalosse
oui voilà de très bien foie gras puis
après quatre faits répond qui sait déjà
arrêtez vous un peu en dessous voilà
dans les landes lui stratège par exemple
puisqu'elle revient sur la vie parce que
l'interview fabriquer squibb elle est
vraiment réussir rallume
j'accueille maintenant
l'accueil maintenant l'un des séismes
les plus pointues sur la critique delà
de la pensée de la vie de notre société
en ce moment tout le monde parle de son
dernier livre
ouais si pascal bruckner
[Applaudissements]
parfois alors et vous excuse
[Musique]
la mère la mère laquelle il y en a plein
[Applaudissements]
j'entendais bien tous les deux ça va en
fait bon ménage
jusqu'ici je crois que c'est vrai que
françoise hardy vous attend de pied
ferme parce que non mais c'est vrai que
l'on parle beaucoup c'est très
intéressant
ça s'appelle l'euphorie perpétuelle
[Musique]
fori perpétuel où le devoir de bonheur
chez grasset par pascal au caire alors
en gros ce que vous dites c'est que les
sociétés occidentales sont unanimement
voué au culte du bonheur aux devoirs de
bonheur la dictature du bonheur et
finalement c'est un peu ce que dit
murray d'ailleurs dans son bouquin lui
parle de la fête obligatoire de l'homo
festivus ce qu'on peut dire c'est qu'en
fait et plusieurs époques avant les
avant la révolution
le bonheur c'était la vie éternelle le
bonheur était pas sur terre mais aussi
alain c'est ça et tout le monde passait
son temps à travailler pour le salut de
son âme
oui oui c'est avec leur époque avec le
christianisme il n'y a pas de bonheur
sur terre mais il ya le soucier du salut
il pour acheter le péché n'existait donc
espérer dans le gros bonheur dans l'au
delà et avec la révolution française
avec voltaire tout change voltaire écrit
le paradis terrestre et là où je suis et
c'est le bouleversement fondamental sur
lequel nous vivons tous encore dire que
le bonheur est rapatrié 6 et non sur la
terre c'est tout de suite et ce droit au
bonheur va s'accentuer tout au long du
19e et du 20e siècle et avec les années
60 tout change aussi une deuxième fois
parce que tout d'un coup plus rien ne
sépare l'individu de son bonheur oui
c'est obstacles traditionnels en sicile
avec mai 68 c'est ici maintenant et
c'est plus seulement ici et maintenant
c'était et c'est toujours et toujours
joué aujourd'hui dire que nous n'avons
plus le droit de ne pas être heureux et
on vit dans une société où les gens pour
la première fois son malheureux
justement de ne pas être heureux parce
que c'est devenu l'horizon idéal des
démocraties et finalement le
renversement extraordinaire c'est que on
finit par se torturer avec quelque chose
qui devrait nous faire plaisir là vous
dit on mais le même acharnement être
heureux que les dévots mettez à aller au
ciel finalement on se donne autant de
mal pour être heureux que pour aller au
ciel on va être heureux à tout prix vous
divisez des formules formidable dit
nous souffrons de ne plus vouloir
souffrir ne pas être heureux nous rend
malheureux
donc on se persécute quotidiennement au
nom d'un épanouissement
c'est ça oui c'est ça c'est le
renversement d'un idéal en son contraire
et on voit les gens effectivement
dépensé une quantité d'énergie
absolument phénoménale à essayer
d'atteindre un bonheur qui les fuit
parce qu'effectivement chaque fois que
l'on cherche le bonheur en tant que tel
il s'évade et le bonheur si on le trouve
éventuellement si tant est qu'on puisse
le trouver c'est toujours de façon
parallèle à travers autre chose mais
chaque fois qu'on dit je veux être
aujourd'hui je veux que ce soit une
bonne journée une journée heureuse sans
la leur il ya toutes les chances pour
qu'il ne se passe pas grand chose vous
dit le mot d'ordre c'est soyez heureux
alors on transmet plus on fait plus d
enfants pour leur transmettre un
héritage matériel ou moral
mais pour qu'il soit heureux et quand le
l'enfant nous dit c'est quoi le bonheur
on lui dit ce que tu veux mon petit
chéri donc finalement non seulement tout
le monde essaye d'être heureux mais en
plus on sait pas vraiment ce que c'est
oui assez ça veut dire que personne
effectivement ne peut dire en quoi
consiste le bonheur on sait que c'est à
l'état satisfaction n'y a pas de contenu
du bonheur pour les uns c'est
l'abstinence pour d'autres c'est
libertinage 23e ce sera la contemplation
au l'action mais quand on dit à
quelqu'un soit heureux on le plonge dans
une perplexité absolue parce que les 10
mai à voir c'est quoi c'est quoi quand
est-ce que je vais être heureux
quel est le signe infaillible il va me
permettre de dire cette fois j'y suis je
suis passé de l'autre côté de la
frontière est alors yahia filia
phénomène dans la vie quotidienne qui
est assez fréquent c'est quand les gens
vous rencontre dans la rue bouddhiste a
bonne mine aujourd'hui vous être achetée
vous faites lors des réunions lui dit
que le bonheur non seulement les
quartiers de noblesse dans le temps
maintenant des quartiers de felicia la
haie et quant à un retour aussi ce que
baudrillard appel l'apocalypse bronzé
quoi et quand l inverse on vous dit oh
tu as ta mauvaise mine alors là vous
êtes sur un clan des parias vous êtes
finis vous êtes obligés d'aller vous
cacher pour retrouver un peu de 7,2 ce
teint qui vous rangera à nouveau du côté
des gens élus aient sauvés alors c'est
un truc qui veut notre bien en plus soit
pas être content le bonheur puisque à
priori c'est un truc qui veut notre bien
et vite si on n'est pas heureux on est
une espèce de culpabilité qui rejoint la
culpabilité judéo chrétienne sur le fait
de parler de pavés au ciel alors c'est
très clair moi je ne sais pas ce que
vous en pensez c'est une idée forte ça
non oui je pense qu'effectivement c'est
un confort mille de l'époque
cette époque est très conformiste et
effectivement cette aspiration au
bonheur en fait obligation du bonheur
fait partie des conformismes de l'époque
moi je trouve c'est une idée très forte
ce bouquin parce que d'un seul coup mais
ça m'a fait du bien parce que depuis que
j'ai lu votre bouquin je me dis dans le
fond oui je me dis maintenant pourquoi
être
et c'est vrai il ya des moments on peut
pas être heureux je veux dire donc ce
n'est pas la peine d'essayer il vaut
mieux vivre les choses comme elles
viennent et puis ton temps ça arrive par
hasard mais c'est vrai qu'on ne supporte
pas le spectacle des gens malheureux ou
malades parce que justement il nous
renvoie d'abord à notre faiblesse et ils
ruinent l'idéal de bonheur et donc on
les fait en se disant si j'ai
fréquentent leurs valeurs vers des
teintes sur moi et je suis fichu et on
refoule le deuil la maladie la mort
parce que c'est pas des choses de
bonheur oui mais j'ai envie d'être
heureuse est ce que ça vaut le coup
parce que ça c'est la vie pour être
parmi d'autres ce qui vous fait beaucoup
plaisir c'est quelques passages de votre
livre que j'ai lu notamment sur le dalaï
lama
ça m'a profondément interpellé comme ds
qui peut choquer orthez par par ce que
vous dites du dalaï lama effectivement
il ya eu des livres un petit peu
insipide qui ont été publiés mais je
crois que vraiment vous le rabaisser
beaucoup en le réduisant à quelqu'un qui
est simplement un optimiste béat je
crois pas du tout que ce soit le cas je
vous dis très surveillée où il habite
fortis a fait dévorer par le système
occidental français le système
médiatique et je remarque aujourd'hui le
dallai lama est contesté au tibet par un
certain nombre de moines qui se disent
nous on fait peut-être fausse route a
fait 25 ans qu'il est en projet
spirituel la condition du peuple
tibétain ne s'améliore pas lui barra de
penser qu'elle se serait améliorée si le
peuple tibétain était entré en guerre
contre la chine il n'y a pas que la
guerre ou dalida maille à partir des
idées avec le bon sourire bienveillant
de sa sainteté où la lutte armée et il
ya eu dans notre siècle mandela il ya eu
grande il ya eu d'autres gens et je
crois que le dalaï lama n'est pas tout à
fait le leader à la hauteur de cette
situation c'est qu'il ne se préoccupe
pas de ce qui se fait là ce teaser à
longueur de temps il essaie de mobiliser
à longueur de temps les jeunes et évite
à son mauvais points après 25 ans tout
ça n'est pas du tout la responsabilité
du dalaï lama c'est la responsabilité du
du monde entier oui mais c'est pourquoi
je m'intéresse à un spécial ou alors
pourquoi cette cause d'intérêts ce parce
que dalila main pas si loin mais c'est
vers cela
il a dit je vais populariser le
bouddhisme pour populariser la cause du
peuple tibétain
résultat les européens jadot mais je
vous jure je ne pense pas que c est la
sauce tibétaine tout le monde s'en moque
parce qu'au fond les bandits sont
tellement sympas qui ne pose aucune
menace aux gouvernements du monde je
sais je sais plus si nous regarde pas ce
que je vais bien j'ai bien aimé ça sa
formule tango down
j'ai bien aimé sa formule quand même
c'est pas très
l'avis de pascal compte c'est que moi
j'ai joué d'un rien n'avance totalement
gratuit et est ce qu'il ya c'est que moi
je trouve formidable le fait que vous
disiez que c'est un gourou monde et moi
c'est la ccba c'est bien c'est facile de
vous approprier
je m'approprie pas moi je pense que je
vais pas rentrer pas rentrer dans le
débat mais c'est vrai qu'on a reçues ici
séverine ferrer qui avait lu un article
un peu négatif sur elle dans voici
qu'est-ce qu'elle accélérait en parler
au dalaï lama et le dalaï lama a reçu
séverine ferrer ça se veut dire alors
vous dites moi dire je suis fou ce qui
est intéressant ce qui est intéressant
dans votre démarche c'est que vous dites
ces dernières pages sont très mobiles
la dernière phrase à l'univers tient non
mais c'est vrai la dernière
non monsieur je déconne pas parce que je
veux vous dire un truc vous dit et nous
quittons la scène sans avoir à peine
goûter aux fastes et ça bien entendu
vous l'avez piquet chez shakespeare un
pauvre acteur qui ne signifie rien c'est
ça qui fait son beurre sur la scène
voilà c'est ça mais c'est totalement
vrai il dit une chose en ce qui concerne
le donneur non moi je présente pas il
est à un truc est formidable et voilà la
gaieté c'est wells et gère le
déploiement voilà de temps en temps on
n'est pas là justement à période
justement de dlc c'est là qu'on voit
c'est toi qui me l'a envoyé alors je
sais bien qu'on peut être émis
vous dites vous des niches fiscales il
vous dîtes le ce que le bonheur
finalement est ce que le but de la vie
c'est le bonheur et est ce que la vie
doit avoir un but déjà un
alors il ya des gens bien ce que vous
faisiez des buts provisoires seront peut
avoir des réussites professionnelles des
réussites amoureuse mais en fait
globalement est ce que la vie doit avoir
un but on est mieux vous dit quand on
est persuadé que la ville n'a pas de but
que ladite insensé mais dire qu'on nous
dit depuis des millénaires set c'était
le christianisme depuis tous les
philosophes que le but de la vie sauve
est le bonheur la recherche de
l'épanouissement mai
je suis pas du tout d'accord je pense
que la vie n'a effectivement aucun but
que c'est une aventure qui n'a pas de
sens on est on est on est sur terre on
ne sait pas pourquoi
et que chercher à savoir pourquoi ces
s'empoisonner l'existence était
appréciée on vous dit que le but de la
vie c'est le bonheur tout ce qui n'est
pas bonne heure dans votre vie alors
c'est rien c'est bon à jeter aux orties
je pense qu'effectivement la vie n'a pas
de sens et c'est peut-être ça qui en
fait lorsque vous évoquez qui lui
donnant des il faut qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont ces gens qui pensent que
le but de la vie c'est de grandir c'est
d'évoluer
c'est d'après moi c'est papa non mais ce
que vous dites de très bien vous dit
finalement la vie c'est des petites
joies ses des instants de plaisir des
smiths et la joie de vivre c'est c'est
très intéressant
l'âge odile c'est accepter tous les
aspects de l'existence qui soit qu'ils
soient bons ou mauvais mais qu'on vit
oui on ne dit pas que du bonheur en vie
on vit tout ce qui arrive le bonheur et
le malheur
oui dans l'adresse du bien dans la joie
dit il ya quelque chose de beaucoup plus
que le bonheur c'est que on peut aimer
la vie que l'on a d'abord parce que
c'était probablement la seule exception
et on peut aussi aimer la vie en dépit
de toutes les blessures qui nous
infligent qu'elle nous caresse auquel
nous détruisent
on aime cette vie parce que c'est
probablement la seule qui n'a pas
d'autre et que donc il faut la savourer
à chacun non mais personne c'est le
contraire non plus je suis d'accord
personne n'est revenu dose là pour nous
dire ça existe deux n'auront que tu peux
faire le pari c'est moi la peinture que
l'on remarque c'est quand même c'est que
cette ville à chevènement a par
chevènement personne n'est revenu de
l'au delà
non mais la regarder oriane unique je
vais lui lire la phrase qu'il a écrit ça
rejoint un peu monsieur quand bien même
les eaux de ces forteresses ceux qui
croyaient un certain nombre de choses se
réveillait pour dénoncer l'absurdité
d'un monde privé de sens n'était ce pas
encore un acte de foi une dérobade
perverse une ultime manière de prier à
l'envers pas mal pas mal
quelque temps un passage aussi moi c'est
ma passion
attention envers aulas non mais c'est
intéressant ce que vous dites de
finalement 2 pour finir vous dit
qu'aujourd'hui seule façon de rester
libre c'est trop que jamais son droit
d'être malheureux ça devrait vous
touchez s'annonce etes vous acceptez
assez bien ça oui mais enfin je trouve
que tout ça est quand même extrêmement
réducteur c'est vraiment comme tout
d'ailleurs ont choisi un angle de vision
et puis on développe tout autour de ça
mais encore une fois ça me paraît très
très réducteur
vous pensez que tu resteras thurella
pendant 11 ans joue un petit peu ce que
vous dites quand cindy en train dans la
chambre les tétons bas mais là non là
sauf si je peux juste vous dire un petit
mot puisque bruckner la livre de pascal
bruckner
son livre est formidable il ya une seul
reproche que je puisse me faire je ne
parle pas de moi le prochain si les deux
voilà bien alors on va passer maintenant
à l'anti portrait chinois l'utah à
attention pareil doit pascal bruckner
voulu laisser le portrait chinois
on va faire lentilles portrait chinois
donc le portrait chinois oui si vous
étiez une fleur vite sur à mieux lotis
sexta lentilles portrait chinois de ses
négatifs
donc si vous étiez un défaut vous saurez
quels défauts l'égoïsme une injure sympa
une maladie le tétanos un accident un
crash d'avion une perversion les câlins
une guerre à dieffenthal une guerre la
guerre des boutons
un microbe la peste un vice le sucre un
dictateur amin dada une arme le fil
dentaire un supplice l'écartèlement une
cicatrice
les bleus à l'âme un poison
poison
un poison curare un [ __ ] dieu le père
un assassin gilles de rais une torture
les caresses une humiliation être
ignorée bravo bravo
et maintenant on va passer en hommage à
pascal bruckner et à son livre
l'euphorie perpétuelle
on va passer un blindtest bonheur
[Musique]
vous connaissez le principe du blind
test françoise hardy françoise enfin
françoise hardy café tous les lunettes
noires du monde
ben oui je sais je suis un peu gâteux
donc il faut trouver qui chante deux
mois un petit exemple pour moi qui
chante françois pour avoir imaginé un
peu si tu sais très bien remédier en
partie
maintenant on commence le premier franc
suisse a terminé le premier qui trouve
on y va didier s'il vous plaît
gendarmes en ont mûri notre vieille
terre est une étoile
[Applaudissements]
alors
je dis une chose au public si les
invités ne trouve pas vous pouvez
répondre et vous serez une star vous
savez pendant 10 secondes un énorme sim
il faut laisser jouer les invités sinon
je fais évacuer la salle
alors d'accord d'accord alors continue
chanson numéro 2
marion une révélation
marchand de bonheur je vais toutes les
cassettes dans la bagnole bien sûr que
toi rover quand c'est pas lui qui trouve
c'est lui moi je crois que vous avez des
accointances dans la production je
n'arrive pas à le croire c'est en effet
nous avons des accointances chanson
numéro 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu pose une question si vous deviez
vous réincarner vous préfériez sheila
sylvie ou france gall
sylvie je pense s'est levée parce que
justement ce que c'est elle qui a le
mieux réussi sa vie sa fin je veux dire
en tout cas dans la vie a été la plus
favorisée sur le plan personnes
sylvie si l'on regarde
chanson numéro 4
[Applaudissements]
c'est écrit en bas d'écran voilà on
continue ça c'est plus difficile des
efforts - marion lui avec ses deux
forcenés j'aimerais qu'on n'a pas les
réponses
un autre extrait je vais vous dire la
noirceur déjà en train de chercher par
cette auto qui veut acheter une
bouteille de bière
didier numéro cinq s'est dit
simon
catherine c'est quoi le score là olivier
2 prévaut un cas d'un françoise hardy
indifférent talent mathilda may s'est
rendu vers une chanson numéro 6 sacha
distel
sélestat
oui la belle dita qui la belle vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attends la première note et 10h indice
tel comme c'est ma femme qui fait de
blind test j'ai commencé à aimer fier de
vous deux non parce que chaque fois vous
touchez un coup franchement et l'armée
yayi ça va on peut être on peut avoir un
moment donné on peut se dire un moment
donné tu veux en même temps chacun le
sens thann on la voit la fin chanson
numéro 7
guy georges est super chaud à 9 heures
[Applaudissements]
ban
je suis à lille et cannes en même temps
catherine absolument mettre un point ça
car ou encore que ça joue pas dans la
même catégorie et clerc william sheller
attendu quand même changé le discours de
mitterrand y ait une chance aux livres
est la première phrase d'un discours a
du talent à cette heure-ci généreux le
chanson à nairobi
[Musique]
tu le dis
spécialisé dans les chaussons de danse
soit les cloches ne sais pas mais si ces
quatre îles mais celle ci s'est calmée
moi je moi je l' ai vu moi je les ai vus
même si la caméra était pas sur lui
c'est un scandale
mais bon est-ce que maintenant qui a
gagné 4 et celui des c4 à gagner est ce
que vous êtes prêts à remettre votre
titre en jeu et faire le super banco
tout à fait c'est quoi j'en sais c'est
bien donc le super banco
didier s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
je souffle pas lui
une personne m'a prouvé à supporter
[Musique]
je
sur le
e
d'ailleurs je
didier super dur je suis content comme
je suis tous vont porter les porter il
ya une autre version qui est par un
crooner didier mai
ce sera demain
comment
ok gagné catherine alors c4 qui
gagnèrent comme d'habitude c'est
horrible à la pression et à voile à
cacher ce que vous allez gagner oui des
danseuses
[Musique]
ok j'ai pas la remercie le ciel tous
étaient donc tout le monde en parle
donc j'en appelle les insaisissables
gameplay beau jeu christian gion a coupé
notre temps j'ai mission du cherche midi
décollage immédiat la cassette prévost
[Applaudissements]
mathilda may là bas mon pays car quasi
avec antoine de caunes et à la rentrée
le temps d'urgence
françoise hardy vers obscures avec le
single puisque vous partez en voyage et
la peur henri emmanuelli citadelle
interdite
pascal bruckner l'autoritaire fait tuer
et kad et olivier la grosse émission sur
comédie
je vais rappeler le titre du bouquin de
pierre bellemare l'empreinte de la paire
[Applaudissements]
disent-elles dans taxi et dans six pack
rendez vous la semaine prochaine
merci
[Musique]
on
non
[Musique]
demain
m
[Musique]
c'est
têtu
m
[Musique]
no
[Applaudissements]